Nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin ein Sieg.
So, und verkennbar, die Klänge des Chaosradios. Ist nicht der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, oder Frank? Ist heute nicht der letzte Mittwoch im Monat.
Heute ist der erste. Wir haben das verschoben freundlicherweise. So sind wir.
Ihr seid so freundlich. Thema ist allerdings natürlich Wehmann Chaosradio. Thema, es wird heute Abend um Patente gehen im Studio. Ganz viele Menschen, viele Gäste zunächst mal. Philipp Börker, angehender Patentanwalt seines Zeichens. Dann Robert Gehring, Informatiker an der TU Berlin und Joachim von Oppen. Der ist Patentanwalt, nicht mal angehender, sondern schon Gassi-gehender sozusagen. Und dann Chaosradio Residenz Frank, Harald und Max anwesend hier im Studio. Patente, wie gesagt, das Thema.
Wir wollen uns heute Abend um Patente kümmern, insbesondere auch um Softwarepatente. Das ist im Moment eine sehr heikel Sache. Wer das ein bisschen verfolgt hat, da stehen neue europäische Vereinheitlichungen an. Es geht darum, das Patentrecht zu vereinheitlichen. Vor allem geht es darum, ob Software- und Algorithmen auch patentiert werden können. Wir wollen uns heute Abend erst mal allgemein über Patente unterhalten, was das eigentlich ist, was das bedeutet, wie funktioniert es mit den Patenten und wollen dann später zu den Softwarepatenten umschwenken und wollen da mal klären, was das heißt, vor allem für die Entwickler von freier Software, von Open-Source-Software und von Leuten, die das nicht beruflich machen und wollen mal gemeinsam diskutieren, was Softwarepatente sind, warum man sie haben will, warum man sie vielleicht nicht haben will und was die Folge davon sind, wenn sie erst mal da sind.
Ja, was habt ihr eigentlich alle jeweils einzelnen mit Patenten zu tun? Insbesondere mal unsere Gäste, fangen wir mal an, von links nach rechts hier im Studio der Robert, eher die Informatikseite wahrscheinlich.
Nicht unbedingt, also ich komme natürlich aus der Informatik, hab auch selber schon Software geschrieben, allerdings ohne mich damals um Patenten zu kümmern, war damals noch nicht so ein Thema. Aber im Zuge meiner verschiedenen Forschungen an der Uni bin ich immer wieder damit konfrontiert worden, hab auch Gutachten schon geschrieben für das Wirtschaftsministerium und berate zum Teil auch Unternehmen, die dann mit der Frage zu uns kommen. Ja, wir haben ja so eine Vermutung, wir wollen Patent anmelden oder wir haben eine Vermutung, da verletzt jemand ein Patent, was wir haben und so. Wie soll man da jetzt vorgehen? Also ist eigentlich für mich ein relativ praktisches Problem schon geworden.
Für mich ist es erst recht praktisch. Ich schreibe zum Beispiel für Erfinder auch Softwarepatenten oder solche Patenten, die man als Softwarepatenten beschreiben würde und vertrete in erster Linie die Interessen der Erfinder, dass halt derjenigen, die glauben, etwas Neues geschaffen zu haben oder derjenigen, die zum Beispiel aus solch einem Patent auch verklagt werden. Also die andere Seite. Insofern kenne ich beide Seiten, kenne auch die damit verbundenen Probleme und bin auch gar nicht ganz eindeutig der Meinung, dass das alles so gut ist, wie es derzeit ist.
Und der Philipp?
Ja, ich bin Patentanwalt Kandidat und möchte das werden, was mein Chef neben mir mal schon ist. Ja, ich komme frisch aus der Industrie. Ich habe mehrere Jahre als Mikrochip-Entwickler gearbeitet und möchte jetzt, nachdem ich selber Erfinder war, lieber dieselben vertreten, weil ich fand, die sind nicht gut genug vertreten.
Hast du dich nicht selber nicht gut genug vertreten gefühlt, so zu sagen?
Nein, ich hatte auch sehr schlechte Erfahrungen mit Patentanwälten, aber auch ein paar gute. Und jetzt hoffe ich, die guten Erfahrungen mit Patentanwälten vermehren zu können. Wie wird man eigentlich Patentanwalt? Das sind ja keine Volljuristen, wie ich letzte Woche gelernt habe, sondern was ist da so die, also wo kommt das Wort Anwalt her? Oder was hat er mit Anwälten zu tun eigentlich? Also Voraussetzung, um Patentanwält zu werden, ist erstmal ein abgeschlossenes Hochschulstudium in einem Ingenieurwissenschaftlichen oder Naturwissenschaftlichen Fach. Außerdem muss man noch über mindestens ein Jahr praktische Arbeitserfahrungen in diesem Beruf verfügen. Die Ausbildung selbst findet gegenwärtig über 26 Monate in einer Patentanwaltskanzlei statt. Der Patentanwaltskandidat wird von einem Patentanwalt ausgebildet, der über mindestens fünf Jahre Berufserfahrung verfügt. Ausbildungsbegleitend gibt es auch noch ein juristisches Fernstudium. Am Ende gibt es dann noch das Praktische Jahr im Patentamt, wo man dann auch noch mal in die Arbeit der Gegenseite sozusagen beim Amt eingeführt wird. Also kein volles Jurastudium? Nein, kein volles Jurastudium.
Ist aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich eine sehr aufwändige Geschichte, wenn du vorher dein Ingenieursstudium abgeschlossen haben musst, plus noch mal jetzt die Zeit der Ausbildung drauf. Wie lange dauert das insgesamt?
Ja, so der Patentanwalt ist glaube ich der Beruf mit der längsten Ausbildungsdauer. Das sind so acht, neun Jahre insgesamt. Bloß das setzt natürlich auch voraus, dass man sich schon von Anfang an dieses Ziel gesetzt hat. Also gewöhnlich, ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe vier Jahre in der Industrie gearbeitet. Es gibt auch Leute, die beginnen die Ausbildung erst in ihren 40ern.
Okay, so um so Späßchen im Alter sozusagen noch zu haben. Ja, Frage des Abends wird natürlich sein, auch für euch in Berlin und Brandenburg. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110 und mitdiskutieren. Patente, sind die gut oder schlecht? Brauchen wir die? Haben wir die wirklich so dringend nötig? Oder sind die der Kropf am Hals der Menschheit? Dann könnt ihr einfach anrufen, eure Meinung dazu abgeben. 0331 77 97 110 und wo wir schon mal so viele Experten da haben. Ihr könnt natürlich auch Fragen stellen, wenn ihr selber schon mal in Kontakt damit gekommen seid, irgendwelche Probleme mit Patenten habt, von welcher Seite auch immer. Dann könnt ihr euch melden und findet hier vielleicht die Antwort heute Abend im Chaos Radio. Frank, gut oder schlecht Patente? Gut oder schlecht ist eine sehr pauschale Frage jetzt natürlich, aber vielleicht kannst du da einfach mal übernehmen, ob ich Patente gut oder schlecht finde oder?
Also am Anfang war ich eigentlich der Meinung, dass Patente also das Patente an sich erstmal eine ganz gute Idee ist. Bei Softwarepatenten war ich da so ein bisschen kritisch, wobei ich mittlerweile, ich muss zugeben, ich habe in den letzten zwei Wochen doch da meine Meinung ein bisschen geändert, dass man das ein bisschen differenzierter sehen muss. Und ja, also die Grenze zwischen normalen Patenten und Softwarepatenten verschwimmt eigentlich ein bisschen, aber ich denke, da werden wir einfach später noch drüber reden. Wir sollten eigentlich am Anfang erst mal so genau klären, was sind eigentlich genau Patente, also dass es da keine Verwirrung gibt bei euch draußen. Was bedeutet eigentlich, ein Patent zu haben? So kurz in drei Sätzen, was ist ein Patent? Wer will? Alle reichen weiter.
Also ein Patent ist letztlich, in erster Linie ein Schutzrecht, und zwar ein Schutzrecht, was ist dem Inhaber des Patentes, der manchmal der Erfinder ist, manchmal auch nicht, erlaubt, anderen das zu verbieten, was durch das erteilte Patent geschützt ist. Dabei muss man ganz klar unterscheiden, bevor ein Patent überhaupt erteilt wird, wird es vom Patentamt geprüft, nämlich dahingehend, ob das, was mit der Patentanmeldung beansprucht wird, überhaupt schutzfähig ist oder nicht. Nur wenn das der Fall ist, also nur wenn die Voraussetzungen, zum Beispiel Neuheit und erfinderische Tätigkeit, also ein gewisses Gewissen, wenn man so will, intellectual level, wenn der gegeben ist, dann gibt es auch ein Patent und man bekommt dieses Schutzrecht und kann damit seine Idee, die man ansonsten ja nur geheim halten könnte, handelbar machen und auch anderen anbieten und dafür zum Beispiel auch sowas wie Lizenzgebühren verlangen, was ein Teil auch der bösen Seite der Patente ist.
Kann ich so mich bei einem Musikstück patentieren lassen?
Nein, das Musikstück, das würde dem Urheberrechtsschutz unterlegen, das heißt, der Urheber erhält den Schutz für sein Schutzrecht, ganz ohne, dass er etwas tun muss, er muss nur das Musikstück geschrieben haben.
Das heißt also Patente sind in erster Linie für Sachen, die jetzt so nicht greifbar sind?
Patente sind in erster Linie für technische Lehren, wie man so schön sagt, also für Dinge, die irgendetwas mit Technik zu tun haben, ob das nun Kugelschreiber ist, eine Glühbirne, ein Auto oder eben auch ein Computer oder auch die Software auf dem Computer, da sind wir wieder beim Thema.
Aber ich stelle mir das unglaublich kompliziert vor, nehmen wir mal an, ich habe irgendwie die Glühbirne erfunden, die ohne Strom funktioniert, trotzdem total hell ist. So, dann komme ich zu dir und dann machst du was. Dann wirst du auf der ganzen Welt abchecken, ob schon irgendein Freak das Ding als Patent angemeldet und erfunden hat oder wie läuft das?
Ein bisschen gucke ich mal, was es da schon gibt. Und erst mal muss ich natürlich dann von dir erklärt bekommen, was du erfunden hast, damit ich das Ganze verstehe. Das Studium, was Philipp Dörker gerade erläutert hat, soll uns dabei helfen, die Erfinder zu verstehen, damit wir die gemeinsame Sprache sprechen. Ich versuche das Ganze zu abstrahieren, irgendwie dahinter ein Konzept zu finden, was die Erfindung eigentlich ausmacht. Das Ganze zu beschreiben, checkt dann ab, übers Internet zum Beispiel, was es da schon gibt, ob das Ganze wirklich neu ist oder ob mir da jemand nur erzählt hat, er hat jetzt die Glühbirne gefunden und in Wirklichkeit leuchtet die schon auf meinem Schreibtisch. Und wenn das aber allzu kompliziert wird, überlasse ich das zum Beispiel dem Patentamt. Ich habe ja gerade gesagt, so eine Patentanmeldung, die muss man schreiben, beim Patentamt einreichen. Und das Patentamt hat dann die Aufgabe zu prüfen, ob das Ganze neu und erfinderisch ist. Das heißt, das Patentamt nimmt diese Recherche in Angriff, denn die kann sehr, sehr aufwendig sein. Und das ist auch klar eine der großen Schwierigkeiten im Patentwesen, dass manchmal, oder es kommt immer wieder vor, dass Dinge plötzlich geschützt werden, die es eigentlich schon gab. Nur weil keiner wusste, dass es sie schon gab.
Okay, wie lange dauert sowas ungefähr? Weil Ämter sind ja ohnehin schon relativ langsam. So die Tradition, bei sowas alles abzuchecken, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dauert einen Moment.
Ich muss zugeben, die sind da sogar beeindruckend schnell. Also wenn man so eine Patentanmeldung eingereicht hat beim Amt, dann bekommt man ein Recherchenergebnis, also einen Hinweis darauf, was es alles schon gegeben hat. Innerhalb von anderthalb Jahren kann man sagen, okay, das ist nicht wirklich überragend schnell. Aber man bekommt sogar bei der ersten Anmeldung das Ergebnis innerhalb von sechs bis neun Monaten. Und die fangen ja nicht immer sofort damit an, muss man ja auch sehen. Nach sechs bis neun Monaten hat man schon mal ein erstes Feedback. Meistens ist das erste Feedback kritisch, weil meistens die Patentanmeldungen so formuliert sind, dass man immer ein bisschen mehr haben will, als man hinterkriegen kann. Und dann sagt einem das Patentamt schon, naja ganz so viel geht nicht. Und das sieht man dann anhand der Entgegenhaltung oder der Prior Art. Die amt dann vorgehalten wird, dass das wohl so nicht gehen kann. Wo muss man sich ein bisschen einschränken im Laufe dieses Verfahrens. Da korrespondiert man als Erfinder oder als Patentanwalt mit dem Patentamt, mit dem Patentprüfer. Und der Prüfer sagt einem dann irgendwann, ne, das geht noch nicht, aus den und den Gründen. Wir sagen ja, okay, ein bisschen weniger. Aber so müsste es eigentlich gehen. Und nach vielleicht zwei Jahren hat man sich dann mit dem Prüfer in der Regel auf das geeinigt, was patentiert werden kann. Und es kann sein, dass das so wenig ist, dass man das Patent gar nicht mehr will. Es kann auch sein, dass man das dann nimmt. Denn Patent darf man auch nicht vergessen. Kostet natürlich erstmal dem Patentinhaber eine ganze Menge Geld.
Was heißt eine ganze Menge?
In der Regel würde man sagen, für eine zum Beispiel deutsche Patentanmeldung so etwas in der Größenordnung 3000 Euro muss man schon investieren, damit man überhaupt so ein Patent kriegt.
Das ist jetzt rein die bürokratischen Kosten oder sind da jetzt auch noch Kosten für einen Patentanwalt schon mit drin?
Da sind schon die Kosten für den Patentanwalt mit drin. Die reine Anmeldegebühr sind nur 60 Euro. Und damit hat man die Anmeldung bezahlt. Wenn man dann noch ein Prüfungsverfahren durchführen will, dann ist man mit knapp 500 Euro dabei. Das muss man dem Amt bezahlen, damit das Amt alles macht und man hinter das Patent erteilt bekommt, dann muss man noch eine Druckkostengebühr bezahlen. Also die ganzen amtlichen Kosten beim deutschen Patent- und Markenamt sind unter 1000 Euro.
Und wie lange hält denn so ein Patent? Wie lange habe ich das da?
Es kann maximal 20 Jahre halten, wenn man alle Jahre die sogenannten Aufrechterhaltungsgebühren zahlt oder Jahresgebühren zahlt. Die steigen im Laufe der Jahre und sind zum Schluss zum Beispiel in Deutschland etwa 2000 Euro teuer. Der Grund ist der, dass man den Patentinhaber schon dazu motivieren will, ein Patent, was er gar nicht nutzt und was ihm nicht bringt, aufzugeben, damit das, was in der Patentanmeldung beschrieben ist, endlich frei für alle wird. Sodass alle das Patent dann auch nutzen können, ganz frei, ohne dem Patentinhaber irgendwas zahlen zu müssen oder ihn um Erlaubnis fragen zu müssen.
Geht nicht darum, dass das Patentamt damit auch tierisch viel Asche macht oder so?
Also ich bin ja gar nicht so sicher, ob die Bilanz des Patentamtes eigentlich insgesamt positiv oder negativ ist. Natürlich lebt das Patentamt auch von diesen Gebühren, das ist gar keine Frage. Und natürlich muss auch der ganze Aufwand für die Recherche und die Erteilung bezahlt werden, dass ein Verfahren, was sich über zum Beispiel zwei, drei Jahre hinzieht, nicht mit den Anmeldegebühren abgedeckt und bezahlt sein kann, ist auch klar.
Gab es einen Begriff Prior Art? Was heißt das genau?
Prior Art ist der, auf Deutsch, Stand der Technik. Das ist all das technische Wissen, was vor dem Anmeldezeitpunkt einer Patentanmeldung schon bekannt war. In irgendeiner Form, zum Beispiel in Zeitungen oder auch verkörpert in irgendwelchen Autos oder Glühbären, die an der Decke hängen. Das alles ist Prior Art oder Stand der Technik. Und gegenüber diesem Stand der Technik muss das, was man beansprucht, neu sein. Das heißt irgendwie anders und auch in einer Weise anders, die nicht selbstverständlich und naheliegend ist. Nur dann gibt es ein Patent.
Ja, ich glaube wir müssen jetzt erstmal Luft holen, oder?
Ja, einen Moment holen wir jetzt mal Luft, lassen das alles sacken und dann geht es aber sofort weiter in der Achterbahn.
Wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten Mal.
Auf Chaos Gasradio auf Fritz 20 nach 10. Thema heute Abend, natürlich ein technisches bzw. vielleicht sogar softwaretechnisches im Laufe des Abends, Patentrecht. Also Patente sind überall drauf, habt ihr alle schon mal mit hantiert. Man weiß es nur meistens nicht, weil es sich alles so subkutan bewegt. Also immer auf so einer Unterebene, die der Normalbürger gar nicht berührt. Ist aber ein sehr interessantes Feld. Und wenn man dann mal damit zu tun hat, dann merkt man auf einmal, ach du meine Güte, kenne ich mich ja überhaupt nicht aus. Wir haben deswegen ganz, ganz viele schlaue Leute heute Abend zu Gast. Den Philipp, den Robert und den Joachim. Philipp ist angehender Patentanwalt. Der Joachim ist es schon. Und Robert ist Informatiker an der TU Berlin. Kennt sich aber mit dem Bereich auch sehr gut aus. Insbesondere dann, wenn es auch um Softwarepatente geht. Und ansonsten noch Frank, Harald und Max, meine Person vom Chaos Radio, dabei. Uwe hat gerade angerufen und hat gesagt, er würde ja ganz gerne mal wissen, weil wir hatten vielleicht, wenn er jetzt erst einschaltet, grob über das Thema Patente geredet. Wie läuft das überhaupt? Wie wird so ein Patent angemeldet? Ein konkretes Beispiel wäre doch mal ganz toll. Also du als Patentanwalt, du weißt, du hast schon mal irgendwas Schönes auf den Tisch gekriegt. Was musstest du dazu mal Geburtshilfe leisten? Was war das zum Beispiel?
Ja, ein ganz konkretes Beispiel hat jetzt nichts mit Software zu tun, sondern ist sehr greifbar. Und zwar kam eines Tages jemand zu mir, der hatte die Idee, einen ganzen Cocktail in einen Eiswürfel zu verpacken. Hat sich gesagt, gut, das Problem ist immer, die ganzen Getränke in den richtigen Kombinationen zusammenzumixen. Das kriegt man in einer Bar auch nicht so schnell hin. Also hat er sich gedacht, ich nehme einen hohlen Eiswürfel, die gab es schon, backt da alles rein, was man für den Cocktail so braucht, außer dem Grundgetränk, zum Beispiel Orangensaft oder so. Das muss man natürlich hinterher noch dazukippen. Dann hat man diesen Eiswürfel mit allem, was da rein gehört, meistens ja alkoholisch, friert nicht so sehr wie der Eiswürfel, kann diesen tollen Eiswürfel, der zum Beispiel innen drin ganz schön rot glimmt, dann in seinen Orangensaft werfen und der platzt. Und in dem Augenblick mischt sich alles, das ist ganz klar. Der platzt auf und alles, was da an Alkohol drin ist und so, das mischt sich gut mit dem Orangensaft und man hat einen tollen Cocktail. Und das sieht auch cool aus, ganz einfach weil das schön Klack macht und so. Und dann muss ich das Ganze, wenn ich das jetzt so vorgestellt bekomme, natürlich beschreiben.
Und ausprobieren natürlich.
Das muss ich eigentlich nicht unbedingt, aber das mache ich natürlich ganz gerne. Aber den Nachweis zum Beispiel, dass es funktioniert, muss ich nicht erbringen, aber in diesem Falle war das natürlich irgendwie naheliegend. Und dann kommt das Ganze trockene, wenn man so will, dann muss ich tatsächlich sagen, was soll ich eigentlich oder was will ich eigentlich schützen. Dann muss ich das in Worten beschreiben, in einem Patentanspruch, der hinterher auch den Schutz definiert und sage, es gibt einen Eiswürfel, der ist in Hol. Und dieser Holraum ist gefüllt mit allen Substanzen, die ich für den Cocktail brauche, mit Ausnahme des Grundgetränkes. Und das ist dann schon eine Definition eines Schutzes. Wenn dann später einer genauso einen Eiswürfel mit diesen Ingredienzchen herstellt, dann verletzt er dieses Patent.
Versuchst du da möglichst kurz zu sein?
Genau, diese Patentansprüche sind immer so aufgebaut, dass nur derjenige verletzt, der von allen Merkmalen, die in diesem Patentanspruch stehen, wirklich Gebrauch macht. Das heißt, ein Merkmal weglassen, zum Beispiel das Eis drumherum, dann verletzt man nicht mehr. Ist auch klar, ich mein, das hat es ja auch schon gegeben.
Und das Ding hast du tatsächlich durchgekriegt?
Das ist durchgegangen, ja.
Ist ja unglaublich.
Aber es war leider, und das hat mich echt ein bisschen traurig gemacht, gar nicht so der Erfolg, den wir uns erhofft haben.
Vielleicht kommt es noch. Gut, das mal so als einzelnes Beispiel. Thema Patente, wenn ihr Fragen habt oder wenn ihr vielleicht schon mal mit Patenten in Kontakt gekommen seid und sagt, puh, finde ich super, finde ich nicht so super oder finde ich interessant, weil ich habe da mal das und das Beispiel an der Hand. 031 77 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und für all diejenigen jetzt total enttäuscht, sind weil sie gerade die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre den Eiswürfeldrink versucht haben zu erfinden und der wartet aber noch nicht so weit. Und es gibt ihn leider schon, wie wir gerade gehört haben. Dann tut mir das natürlich auch in der Seele weh. Aber vielleicht wird sich das wieder lösen, weil wir haben ja noch ganz viel Zeit zu diskutieren bis 1 Uhr heute Nacht. Ins Thema gehen wir gleich etwas genauer rein. Vielleicht gibt es erst mal die Nachrichten hier auf Fritz. Und danach etwas spezieller dann zum Thema Patente.
Wenn Fritz ein Steglitz und Willmastow, dann 102, 6.
Wir haben es 22.30 gleich. Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht gibt es wenig Wolken und kein Regen. Das bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 9 und 4 Grad. Vorsicht stellenweise gibt es auch Nebel. Morgen wird es allerdings schön sonnig und trocken bei Werten zwischen 20 und 24 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötterheinrich.
Beim Überfall auf eine Schule in Südrussland haben mutmaßliche tschechenische Extremisten bis zu 300 Kinder, Lehrer und Eltern in ihre Gewalt gebracht. Die Geiselnemmer drohen damit, die Schule in die Luft zu sprengen und Geiseln zu erschießen. Die Extremisten fordern den Abzug aller russischen Truppen aus Tschechienien. Das Bundeskabinett hat Änderungen bei den Arbeitsmarktreformen beschlossen. So soll das Arbeitslosengeld II bereits Anfang Januar 2005 ausgezahlt werden. Außerdem dürfen Kinder von Arbeitslosengeld II Beziehern jetzt bis zu 4.100 Euro besitzen, ohne dass das Geld angerechnet wird. Die Grünen-Fraktion hat am Abend ihre beiden Vorsitzenden Kathrin Göring-Eckardt und Christa Sager für weitere zwei Jahre im Amt bestätigt. Im Mittelpunkt der zweitägigen Sitzung steht die Überprüfung der Reform des Arbeitsmarktes sowie weitergehende Reformen in der Gesundheitspolitik und der Pflegeversicherung. In Venedig ist das 61. Filmfestival eröffnet worden. Zum Auftakt wird das neue Werk von US-Regisseur Steven Spielberg, The Terminal, gezeigt. Der Film mit Tom Hanks in der Hauptrolle läuft außerhalb der Konkurrenz. Insgesamt bewerben sich in diesem Jahr 21 Filme um den goldenen Löwen. Der Verkehr, Fritz, mit einer Meldung A115, das ist die Avus, statt auswärts Richtung Potsdam zwischen Funkturm und Kleinmachno fährt ein Schwertransport. Da kommt er nicht dran.
Fritz präsentiert The Darkness Apokalyptica Motorhead Und viele mehr.
Kurz gesagt, Fritz präsentiert Werner das Rennen. Ein herzerfrischendes Moin Moin an alle durchgeknallten. Jede Menge Musik und dazu jede Menge Motoren. In allen Gründen, in voller Lautstärke und in rauen Mengen. Mehr Infos Fritz.de und im Radio.
Und ihr hört das Chaosradio. Auf Fritz 22.30 Uhr, noch zweieinhalb Stunden sind Zeit zu diskutieren über das Thema Patente heute Abend. Chaosradio auch mal nicht am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, sondern leicht verschoben. Nehmt euch das, also euch braucht das auch nicht übel zu nehmen, aber uns vielleicht dann auch nicht. Gäste im Studio zum Thema Patente, wir haben uns abgesichert bis zum Get-Know, damit bloß jede Frage beantwortet werden kann, sind Philipp Berker, angehender Patentanwalt, dann der schon sehende Patentanwalt, Joachim von Oppen und Robert Gehring, Informatiker von der TU Berlin. Ansonsten vom Chaosradio-Team im Studio Frank und Harald und meine Person der Max. Thema wie gesagt Patente. Ein bisschen die Einführung, was das überhaupt ist, haben wir ja gerade schon geliefert. Jetzt geht's so langsam ins Detail.
Wir wollen jetzt noch mal ein bisschen den Unterschied aufdröseln zwischen Urheberrecht und Patentrecht. Das heißt also wo sind auch mal so die feinen, aber wichtigen Unterschiede, vor allem wenn es nachher um die Software geht, über die wir heute Abend auch reden wollen, also um Softwarepatente. Und da würde ich gerne noch mal von euch ein bisschen wissen, wo eigentlich so, wo ihr da die, also was so die wichtigen Unterschiede sind, wo es herkommt, was so die praktisch die Entstehungsgeschichte zum einen, also Urheberrecht nicht, aber vor allem von Patenten. Und warum gibt es Patente, warum gibt es, warum sind Patentanmeldungen oder Patente nicht schon durch das Urheberrecht gedeckt und andersrum, das heißt, warum kann ich ein Musikstück nicht patentieren lassen? Ja, wer will da noch mal ein bisschen was zu sagen? Also so, das Urheberrecht schützt Werke, während das Patentrecht eben Erfindungen schützt. Ein Werk ist erstmal durch sich selbst eigentlich nur gekennzeichnet. Ich kann zum Beispiel eine Geschichte von Goethe in eigenen Worten nacherzählen oder auch von einem aktuellen Schriftsteller. Das kann dann tatsächlich eventuell wieder Schöpfungshöhe erreichen. Für dieses Werk würde dann wieder Urheberrecht bestehen können. Bei einem Patent ist es nur wiederum so, dass die Idee einer Erfindung geschützt werden soll und folglich auch vor Nachahmung geschützt wird. Also wenn ich eine bestimmte Maschine baue, könnte jetzt jemand anders das nicht unbedingt nachbauen mit leicht abgeänderten Schaltelementen oder sowas. Das würde höchstwahrscheinlich noch durch das Patent geschützt werden. Also es geht darum, das Verfahren als solches zu schützen. Wie die Maschine arbeitet. Das heißt, ich beschreibe in der Patentanmeldung, wie die Maschine arbeitet. Richtig? Ja, genau. Also das ist ein ganz wesentlicher Bestandteil eines Patentes, das immer die technische Lehre auch dargelegt werden muss in der Patentschrift. Also sie ist dann der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich. Im Austausch dafür bekommt der Erfinder dann halt eben die Nutzungsrechte eingeräumt für den Zeitraum, in dem er eben das Patent halten möchte oder maximal eben die 20 Jahre Laufzeit, die ein Patent haben kann.
Aber warum ist es denn nötig? Warum kann man nicht sagen, Urheberrecht ist halt auch auf solcherlei Dinge auszuweiten?
Ja, das hat einfach mit der Natur des Schutzgegenstandes zu tun. Für eine Maschine ist jetzt irgendwie das Urheberrecht eigentlich relativ ungeeignet, weil einfach welchen Aspekt möchte ich daran jetzt speziell schützen? Das Design oder nur den Schaltplan? Ich meine, letztendlich geht es doch darum, wie man eine bestimmte technische Aufgabe dann tatsächlich löst. Und das soll geschützt werden. Wenn ich jetzt so ein Patent habe, dann ist ja die Patentschrift als solche, dann ist sie einsehbar von jedem. Das heißt also jeder hat dann die Möglichkeit zu schauen, wie diese Maschine funktioniert.
Richtig? Das ist richtig, ganz genau. Aber erst nach anderthalb Jahren. Es ist so, dass man eine Patentanmeldung einreicht, beim Patentamt und sie erst nach anderthalb Jahren veröffentlicht wird. Ich möchte nur einmal kurz zurückkommen auf den Unterschied zwischen Urheberrecht und Patent. Mit einem Wort. Das Urheberrecht schützt im Grunde die äußere Erscheinung eines Werkes oder den Text eines Werkes. Das ist ganz klar. Da kommt es auch irgendwo her. Während ein Patent eigentlich mehr die Funktion oder den technischen Aufbau eines Gegenstandes schützt. Also mehr in Richtung Funktionalität geht. Das ist gerade im Zusammenhang mit der Software ganz entscheidend. Software ist ja auch Urheberrecht geschützt. Und das betrifft dann nur den Quelltext. Man kann sie aber auch patentrechtlich schützen und hat dann die Funktionalität.
Ein wichtiger Punkt ist, also man kann sich grundsätzlich merken, das eine schützt die Form, das ist das Urheberrecht, und das andere schützt die Funktion, das ist patentrechtlich. Immer da, wo beides gleichzeitig auftritt, wie bei Software, dann kann man unter Umständen diesen Doppelschutz in Anspruch nehmen. Ein ganz wesentlicher Unterschied zwischen den beiden Sachen ist, dass das Urheberrecht mir Schutz für mein Werk, das ich geschaffen habe, gibt, aber nicht verhindert, dass jemand anderes, der ein quasi identisches Werk, völlig unabhängig von mir schafft, dafür einen eigenen Schutz bekommt. Das heißt, ich selber darf zum Beispiel mein Werk, wenn ich ein Bild gemalt habe, hat eine bestimmte Form, dafür ist es geschützt, dann darf ich das Werk verkaufen und so weiter. Ich habe dafür den Urheberrechtsschutz, ich kann anderen Leuten verbieten, es einfach zu kopieren. Wenn aber zufälligerweise mein, weiß ich nicht, Namensvetter in Paris ebenfalls ein sehr, sehr ähnliches Werk zu gleichen Zeit oder auch zum anderen Zeitpunkt erfunden, er entwickelt hat, in Anführungszeichen, ein Bild gemalt hat, was so sehr ähnlich aussieht wie meins. Es ist aber keine Kopie. Ich kann auch nicht zeigen, dass es eine Kopie ist, sondern er kann mir zeigen, ne ne ne, er wusste von mir nichts, von meinem Bild. Dann hat er dafür selbst einen Schutz und kann das ebenfalls verkaufen. Bei Patenten ist es nicht so. Wenn ich eine Erfindung mache und ich melde diese Erfindung an und bekomme dafür ein Patent erteilt, dann kann mein Namensvetter in Paris, die selbe Erfindung gemacht haben, völlig unabhängig von mir, aber er kann dann, wenn ich entsprechendes Patent beispielsweise in Deutschland und in Frankreich angemeldet habe, kann ich zum Patentamt gehen und sagen, ich möchte auch ein Patent darauf haben. Er darf auch nicht etwa das Ganze sozusagen produzieren, was er da geschützt hat und dann verkaufen. Das kann ich ihm verbieten. Und das geht im Urheberrecht nicht. Das ist ein deutlicher Unterschied. Ein wesentlicher Unterschied ist die sogenannte Schutzdauer. Patente sind 20 Jahre lang nach der Anmeldung geschützt, während Urheberrecht 70 Jahre nach dem Tode des Künstlers in Anführungszeichen, der den Schutz bekommen hat für sein Werk, gilt. Was natürlich eine viel längere Zeitspanne ist. Im Fall von Software, wo also sowohl die Form durch das Urheberrecht geschützt ist, als auch die Funktion unter Umständen durch Patentrecht, haben wir also einen doppelten Schutz, der einerseits diese 20 Jahre durch das Patentrecht an die anderen sind auf der anderen Seite die 70 Jahre nach dem Tode des Urhebers. Also wenn ich das Programm geschrieben habe mit 20 Jahren und ich starbe mit 70, dann sind da 50 Jahre schon mal geschützt die ganze Geschichte und dann noch weitere 70 Jahre nach meinem Tode.
Das heißt, solange gibt es Software noch nicht, dass da schon irgendein Patent abgelaufen wäre wahrscheinlich, oder?
Doch, Patente abgelaufen sind bei Software schon. Also Software, die ersten Softwareprogramme...
Wir quatschen also Urheberrechtlich, Entschuldigung, die lange Variante, sorry.
Allerdings muss man dazu sagen, dass Urheberrechtsschutz für Software erst seit den 70er Jahren überhaupt existiert. Insofern gab es sozusagen vorher schon Programme, inwieweit dann noch der Schutzanspruch besteht oder nicht. Das müsste man im Einzelfall diskutieren, das kann man so pauschal gar nicht sagen.
Und ich denke, ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied ist, dass man Patente anmelden muss. Das heißt, ich muss mir sehr aktiv drum kümmern. Und das Urheberrecht bekomme ich einfach, das ist einfach da. In dem Moment, wo ich ein Werk schaffe, habe ich das Urheberrecht dafür. Und muss da also nichts formal irgendwo anmelden oder so, sondern das habe ich halt einfach.
Genau, das entsteht automatisch mit dem Akt der Schöpfung quasi. In dem Moment, wo ich ein Programm geschrieben habe, habe ich daran ein Urheberrecht. Ein Patentrecht bekomme ich im Zweifelsfall dann, wenn ich zum Patentanwalt gehe und der mir eine entsprechende Schrift aufsetzt und sagt, oh, ganz tolle Geschichte hier, einen virtuellen Eiswürfel, einen virtuellen Cocktail-Eiswürfel erfunden. Gab es noch nicht. Und der Patentprüfer sagt auch, oh, tolle Sache hier und so, gibt einen Patent drauf. Und dann gibt es demnächst den virtuellen Cocktail-Eiswürfel als Bildschirmschoner mit irgendwelchen Gravitationseffekten und so.
Es darf übrigens auch jeder selbst zum Patentamt gehen. Braucht nicht unbedingt einen Patentanwalt. Aber das macht es natürlich leichter, wenn man jemanden hat, der schon mal da gewesen ist.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Wen nützen solche Patente überhaupt? Wer braucht Patente? Also mal abgesehen von dem Eiswürfeltypen.
Nach dem, was wir gerade diskutiert haben, gibt es ja auch einige der Ansichten, die nützen niemanden. Aber es gibt zwei Argumente, die für Patente sprechen. Zum Beispiel das Argument, dass der Erfinder ja dafür, dass er seine Erfindung schützt oder anmeldet zum Patent, auch den Deal eingeht, dass die Anmeldung nach 18 Monaten veröffentlicht wird, sodass alles, was er sich ausgedacht hat und was er ansonsten nur durch Geheimhaltung schützen könnte, dann öffentlich bekannt wird. Das ist eine verbreitete Theorie zur Stützung des Patentierungsgedankens. In diesem Sinne nützt es der Allgemeinheit. Dann nützt natürlich das Patent, man sagt ja vielleicht den Patentinhaber, allerdings muss man auch da fairerweise sagen, erstmal schadet es ihm, denn er muss eine ganze Menge Aufwand treiben, bis er das Patent überhaupt bekommt, muss was bezahlen. Und es nützt ihm erst dann etwas, wenn seine Idee auch wirklich von irgendjemand aufgegriffen wird, verwirklicht wird, sich verkaufen lässt und er dann zum Beispiel Nizenzgebühren einnehmen kann. Dann kann er für die Entwicklung seiner Idee, die näher nicht immer so spontan ist wie der Eiswürfel, sondern manchmal auch wirklich auf 10 Jahre harte Arbeit zurückgeht, die Früchte genießen.
Ich würde gerne nochmal auf diese Erfindungshöhe, was muss ich eigentlich tun, damit ein Patent sozusagen eine Aussicht hat anerkannt zu werden? Also muss ich da jetzt lange Forschung nachweisen oder kann ich über Nacht einfach eine Eingebung haben? Welche Kriterien gibt es dafür? Das ist glaube ich auch ein weit verbreitetes Irrtum, dass man bei der Frage, ob Patente denn gerechtfertigt sind oder nicht, ob ich jetzt da was dafür tun muss oder nicht. Wie sieht es aus? Was muss ich tun für einen Patent? Wie viel muss ich da irgendwie nachweisen, dass ich da etwas rein investiert habe, Forschung betrieben habe? Also für einen Patent oder für die Erteilung eines Patentes gibt es drei Kriterien, drei Voraussetzungen. Es muss neu sein. Das darf also die Erfindung noch nicht existiert haben. Sie muss auf einer erfinderischen Tätigkeit beruhen. Das werde ich gleich noch erklären. Und sie muss gewerblich anwendbar sein. Die gewerbliche Anwendbarkeit, die kann man eigentlich immer als gegeben ansehen. In Zweifel findet man immer jemand, der einen dafür bezahlt. Und außerdem werde ich bestimmt keine Amtsgebühren zahlen, wenn ich mir nicht erhoffe, diese Erfindung auch verwerten zu können. Die erfinderische Tätigkeit bedeutet letztendlich, dass ein Fachmann, der über das aktuelle Wissen verfügt, nicht in naheliegender Weise auf den Gegenstand der Erfindung gelangen kann. Und darum gibt es eigentlich dann immer die intensivsten Streite, ob nun eine Erfindung eben erfinderisch ist, also tatsächlich nicht nahegelegen hat oder eben doch. Die Erfindungshöhe, muss man sagen, dass man Irrglaube, dass da irgendein Kriterium existiert, der ergibt sich eigentlich nur indirekt aus der Vorgabe der erfinderischen Tätigkeit. Also eine Erfindungshöhe kann ja auch niemand messen. Was soll das sein? Irgendwie zehn Zeilen in der Patentanmeldung müssen mindestens neu sein und da muss der Prüfer sagen, wow, das habe ich noch nie gehört. Oder sollen es hundert Zeilen sein oder was muss da drin stehen? Deswegen geht man eigentlich zurück auf dieses Kriterium der erfinderischen Tätigkeit.
Und im Zusammenhang mit Software und Computern gibt es da noch eine kleine Nuance dazu. Und zwar gibt es ja auch Algorithmen, die sich quasi automatisch weiterentwickeln. Und wenn dann so ein Algorithmus, einen anderen Algorithmus produziert, dann erfüllt dieser nicht das Kriterium der erfinderischen Tätigkeit. Das heißt nämlich, da muss ein Erfinder dahinter stehen. Das heißt, jemand muss die Idee gehabt haben. Und ein Softwareprogramm, was selbst in Anführungszeichen ein anderes Softwareprogramm hervorbringt, hat keine Idee gehabt im Sinne des Patentrechts. Da gab es schon mal Streitlichkeiten drum herum, als man diskutiert hat, auch im Urheberrecht zum Beispiel. Was ist denn, wenn ein Programm sich selbst modifiziert? Gibt es solche Programme? Ja, klar. Und was ist dann eigentlich mit dem Code, der sozusagen von dem Programm generiert wurde? Programm geschrieben ist. Es hat auch keinen Urheber. Dann gibt es auch keinen Urheberrechtsschutz für diesen Bestandteil, der dabei entstanden ist.
Aber es gibt auch viele, viele Programmierer oder auch Software-Erschaffer, die sich erst mal sozusagen ein Programm schreiben, das für sie dann bestimmte Sachen erledigt. Also zum Beispiel bei Spielen wird ja auch erst mal eine sogenannte Engine programmiert, mit der dann das Spiel an sich gebaut wird. Lässt sich das dann auch nicht schützen?
Doch. Geschützt ist dann quasi diese Engine und dann sind die Bestandteile. Aber es gibt ja diese genetischen Algorithmen, nennen die sich zum Beispiel, und die entwickeln sich selbst weiter. Das heißt, da weiß auch derjenige, der diesen Algorithmus vorher programmiert hat, gar nicht, was dabei rauskommt. Er guckt einfach zu, was da passiert. Und dann gibt es zwar entwegen Testverfahren, die sagen dann, oh, dieser Algorithmus, der sortiert jetzt aber schneller als der andere. Aber in dem Moment hat den weder jemand erfunden, noch hat jemand ein Urheberrecht an diesem Code. Weil da stand niemand dahinter, der das geschrieben und erfunden hat.
Das ist doch toll.
Jaja, im Prinzip schon. Leider für den Alltag nicht so getaugt.
Und das Verfahren um diesen Code, also diesen sich fortpflanzenden Code oder weiterentwickelnden Code, ist das natürlich dann auch patentierbar?
Das ist dann wiederum patentierbar, ja. Aber das, was dabei rauskommt, nicht mehr.
Da muss man wirklich echt nochmal eine ganz andere Ausbildung mitbringen, um dadurch zu leben.
Vielleicht doch nochmal einsteigen an der Stelle die Frage, ob dann dieses Verfahren patentierbar ist oder nicht, die ist doch offen, also die ist doch nicht gegeben. Ich mein...
Nee, ist nicht zwangsläufig patentierbar, sondern es könnte patentierbar sein. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfalle entscheidet der Patentprüfer dann darüber, ja ja, es ist patentierbar. Aber es muss natürlich die vorgenannten Kriterien einfach erfüllen.
Wir haben einen Anrufer. 0373 77 97 110. Übrigens die Nummer. Um hier mitzuwirken beim Chaosradio und zum Thema Patente, Fragen zu stellen oder Bemerkungen abzugeben, könnt ihr genauso tun wie der, ich nehme mal an, das ist ein Pseudonym, Sheriff aus Langwitz.
Guten Abend.
Du hast von einem merkwürdigen Patent gehört. Du möchtest Fragen zu stellen.
Und zwar hat jemand seinen Namen in einer merkwürdigen Schreibweise patentiert lassen. Und zwar so, dass ein Autohersteller wollte sein Auto so nennen und die haben ihm das Patent abgekauft.
Ich habe davon nicht gehört, aber kann was Wahres dran sein. Das würden wir nicht Patent nennen, sondern das wäre der Markenschutz. Das ist auch noch eine Form von geistigen Eigentum neben den Urheberrechten, den Patentschutz, mit dem man eben Marken schützt. Also die Bezeichnungen, unter denen Gegenstände verkauft werden oder Dienstleistungen erbracht werden. Und die Marken können natürlich reine Worte sein, aber auch Logos oder eben Worte und Logos verknüpft, zum Beispiel Worte in einer bestimmten grafischen Gestaltung.
Also die Sache war gewesen, jemand hat seinen Namen in der bestimmten Schreibweise. Also der heißt Turan. Und jetzt wisst ihr auch, welcher Hersteller. Also VW wollte das Auto so nehmen. Und denen ist anscheinend dieser Fehler unterlaufen. Die haben diesen Namen halt nicht schützen lassen, bevor sie das Auto produziert haben. Und die hat dann halt in bestimmten Betracht uns dieses Auto gekriegt.
Aber darf der seinen Namen jetzt nicht mehr benutzen? Oder was heißt der jetzt Peter?
Nee, die Sache ist ja, Turan wird ja nicht so geschrieben, wie der Turan, wie der Dingsda, wie das Auto heißt. Also ist schon eine abgeänderte Form gewesen.
Also der Markenschutz bezieht sich ja auch meist nur auf eine Gattung, oder?
Genau, Marken kriegt man nicht gleich für alles auf einmal, sondern muss schon sagen, wofür man die Marke anmelden will. Und dann kommt es natürlich darauf an, ob die Marke sich ähnlich anhört. Das könnte hier zum Beispiel der Fall sein, oder ob sie ähnlich geschrieben wird, oder ob sie ähnlich aussieht. Und wenn da sowas wie Verwechslungsgefahr besteht, dann ist eine Markenverletzung möglicherweise gegeben. Und da muss man sich darum kümmern. Da kann was Wahres dran sein, ja. Ich kenne die Geschichte nicht, aber es kann gut sein.
Hoffentlich nennen die ein Auto irgendwann Maximilian, dann bin ich reich und kriege die Karre auch sofort.
Hast du die Marke schon angemeldet?
Nein, nein, natürlich nicht. So nennt man noch kein Auto. Wenn ihr ähnliche Fragen habt oder euch was Ähnliches unterlaufen ist, könnt ihr gerne mit quatschen. Wo soll es lang gehen, Frank?
Wir wollen noch mal ein bisschen die Frage aufgreifen, wem nützen die Patente, wem schaden sie möglicherweise. Da sind wir vorhin so ein bisschen stehen geblieben. Das würde ich gerne noch mal ein bisschen weiter besprechen. Und vielleicht machen wir noch ein bisschen kurz Musik zum Luft holen.
Wir können auch mal eben den Patrick noch annehmen. Ja, der hat sich gerade hier durch die Schleife gemogelt aus Krefeld. Na, Patrick?
Ja, guten Abend. Ja, und zwar habe ich mal eine Frage zum Patentrecht. Wie sieht das denn aus, wenn ich jetzt mir überlege, oder wenn wir in Deutschland hier kein Patentrecht haben oder hätten und ich in Amerika einen Patent anmelde oder in einem anderen Land und möchte dann hier in Deutschland halt ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen, was dieses Patent beinhaltet. Geht das oder geht das nicht?
Die Antwort ist ganz einfach. Wenn es das Patent nur in Amerika gibt, dann kann man das hier in Deutschland ohne weiteres machen. Der Patentschutz ist immer territorial begrenzt auf die Länder, wo man das Patent beantragt und auch dann hinterherteilt bekommen hat. Das ist übrigens auch ein Unterschied zum Urheberrecht, was nämlich weltweit wirkt.
Aha, das heißt also hier in Deutschland dürfte ich das Produkt dann verkaufen, allerdings darf ich es nicht in dieses Land exportieren, wo halt dieses Patent existiert.
Ganz genau, man darf es auch da nicht herstellen lassen und man darf es da nicht anbieten, was manchmal mit dem Internet Probleme bereitet.
Ganz kurz nochmal, so was wie Pharmafirmen, es gibt ja diese große Diskussion um AIDS-Medikamente zum Beispiel in Afrika. Haben die das Ding in Afrika auch patentieren lassen? Weil sonst könnte ja irgendjemand einfach das Medikament da herstellen.
Das ist richtig, wenn es da keinen Patentschutz gibt. Das ist ja der Grundgedanke, alles was nicht geschützt ist, darf man machen.
Aber die werden wahrscheinlich in jedem kleinen Land der Welt patentiert haben, oder?
In jedem Fall glaube ich sogar nicht mal, sondern das Problem ist, dass die Fabriken, in denen man die Medikamente herstellen kann, die sind relativ teuer zu errichten. Deswegen gibt es in Afrika in der Regel diese Fabriken nicht. Ursprünglich war es dann eben so, dass die in Indien die Medikamente hergestellt haben, oder in Brasilien zum Beispiel, und die danach Afrika geschafft haben. Und in Brasilien wiederum bestand dann zum Teil sogar Schutz. Das heißt, die haben das Patent verletzend hergestellt zum Teil. In Indien war es so, dass bis vor kurzem Medikamente nicht in Patentschutzunterlagen, sodass Indien das ganz legitim herstellen konnte und nach Afrika exportieren konnte. Und da hat die US-Regierung also mächtig Druck gemacht über die WTO, um zu erzwingen, dass die Inder ihre Gesetze ändern. Und daraufhin haben also jetzt in Indien gibt es auch Patentschutz für Medikamente. Und damit kann dann Indien nicht mehr einfach die Medikamente herstellen und nach Afrika verschiffen. Und inzwischen haben sich inzwischen die meisten amerikanischen Staaten auch vertraglich verpflichtet, bis 2015 oder so, den Patentschutz einzuführen. Also dann hat sich das Problem so gesehen ja auch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise erledigt.
Die Brasilianer haben sich sowieso eine Sonderregelung irgendwie auserkoren für ihren lokalen Markt oder für Brasilien, dass sie sämtliche Medikamente herstellen dürfen, ohne Rücksicht auf Patente. Sofern der Patentinhaber nicht innerhalb einer bestimmten Zeit frisst, die Medikamente im Land, sprich in Brasilien herstellt. Das ist noch so eine Ausnahmeregelung, die die für sich eingeführt haben.
Und wieso können die den Druck machen? Und warum lassen sich die Inder bzw. die Afrikaner dann von den USA über die WTO irgendwie erpressen und die Brasilianer nicht?
Na ja, das ist alles nur eine Frage der Zeit, würde ich sagen.
Das geht übrigens auch manchmal umgekehrt. Auch die Amerikaner haben sich im Rahmen der WTO-Verhandlungen an einige Dinge angepasst, die es bis dahin in den USA nicht gab. Da gab es zum Beispiel die Gegebenheit, dass eine Patentanmeldung, solange sie nicht erteilt wurde, nicht veröffentlicht wurde. Und wenn das Erteilungsverfahren sich 17 Jahre hingezogen hat oder 20, dann wurde die Patentanmeldung erst nach 20 Jahren als Patent veröffentlicht und lebte dann noch 17 Jahre. Das hat wiederum hier natürlich einigen gestunken und hat dazu geführt, dass die Amerikaner sich an dieser Stelle ein bisschen gebeugt haben. Übrigens, was diese Ausnahme angibt in Brasilien, das gibt es eigentlich auch in fast allen Ländern, wo es Patente gibt, dass man sagt, wenn eine wirkliche Unterversorgung der Bevölkerung an bestimmten Medikamenten droht, dann gibt es auch so etwas wie Zwangslizenzen, dann dürfen auch andere so etwas machen.
Wobei man natürlich dazusagen muss, gerade im Zuge der Antrax-Debatte in den USA gab es ja dann ebenfalls die Frage, ob denn das Medikament, was Bayer, glaube ich, in den USA gegen Antrax-Infektionen herstellt, ob das dann mit dem Preis überhaupt in hinreichender Menge gekauft werden kann, um die Bevölkerung damit zu versorgen. Und dann wurde ja in den USA schon stark darüber diskutiert, ob man denn jetzt den Patentschutz da für dieses Medikament einschränken, aufheben müsse und so weiter und so fort. Da gab es einen großen Aufschrei. Und nachdem also diese Diskussion, also dieser Druck auch auf den Hersteller eigentlich da war, haben dann die Hersteller gesagt, na gut, wir verkaufen es der US-Regierung, glaube ich, im Gesundheitsministerium oder wem auch immer, da für einen halben Preis. Und daraufhin hat sich das Ganze mehr oder weniger im Wohlgefallen aufgelöst. Aber es ist schon richtig so, dass man grundsätzlich diese Zwangslizenzen verteilen kann. Allerdings, glaube ich, ist es in Deutschland in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik bisher erst ein oder zwei Mal vorgekommen und dann auch wieder rufen worden im Nachhinein. Also in der Praxis haben diese Zwangslizenzen eigentlich eine sehr geringe Bedeutung.
Das kann man natürlich als Land auch nur machen, wenn man eine gewisse Lobby hat. Also wenn man eine gewisse Art von Druck ausüben kann.
Ja, zum einen das und zum anderen muss man sich auch politisch erst mal durchsetzen gegen die eigene Industrie in zweifels Falle, was auch nicht immer trivial ist. Man weiß ja, dass die Politiker durchaus ein offenes Ohr haben und in Aufsichtsräten sitzen oder befreundet sind mit irgendwelchen Betriebsräten. Und ich weiß nicht was. Da gibt es dann schon natürlich einen gewissen Lobbyismus.
Ganz kurz bevor Patrick denkt, wir haben ihn vergessen. Patrick, du weißt Antworten fallen natürlich bei so vielen Leuten immer etwas umgreifender aus, nicht? Du wolltest vielleicht noch weiter argumentieren? Weil wir wären da so reingegratscht.
Ich wollte nur ganz kurz fragen, und zwar wenn ich jetzt das Copyright-Gesetz habe, oder das Urheberrecht-Gesetz ja, das würde dann allerdings weltweit gelten. Also wenn ich hier einen Text habe, und dort melde ich meinen, ja dass ich das geschrieben habe irgendwie an, und das geht dann allerdings weltweit, oder wie sieht das aus?
Anmelden muss das ja schon mal nicht.
Genau, genau. Es gibt viele Länder, die ein Urheberrecht eh nicht dem Deutschen oder dem Amerikanischen haben, das davon ausgeht, dass das Urheberrecht mit Schöpfung des Werkes entsteht. Und in all denjenigen Ländern, wo das so ist, da entsteht eben das Urheberrecht mit Schöpfung des Werkes und wirkt dann auch in diesen Ländern, auch wenn das Werk in einem anderen Land geschaffen worden ist.
Also da gibt es einfach internationale Verträge darüber, in denen sich nahezu alle Staaten weltweit, also ich glaube 198 oder sowas, vertraglich verpflichtet haben, die Urheberrechte von Urhebern aus anderen Ländern anzuerkennen. Und damit bekommst du in Deutschland die Urheberrechte aus dem Deutschen Gesetz und in den USA eben die aus dem US-Gesetz. Und die sind eben über diese Verträge sehr stark angeglichen, sodass der effektive Schutz schon nahezu identisch ist.
Welche sind die wichtigen Organisationen dafür? Oder die wichtigen Institutionen weltweit?
Also diese ganzen Verträge werden von der World Intellectual Property Organization im Wesentlichen verwaltet. Die ist eine Unterorganisation der UNESCO mit Sitz in Genf, glaube ich. Und die wichtigsten Verträge momentan vielleicht sind die sogenannte Revidierte Berner Übereinkunft, das ist schon ziemlich alt zum Urheberrecht. Und dann gibt es noch die sogenannten WIPO Treaties, also das sind quasi Urheberrechtsverträge fürs Internet, Zeitalter, für digitale Information.
Vielleicht übrigens dazu noch ein Hinweis, das hat sich als Diskussion ergeben. Man kann sich natürlich überlegen, ob man seine Patente nur in den Ländern anmeldet, wo man ein Medikament überhaupt herstellen kann, oder in den Ländern, wo man es verkaufen will. Beides ist gleichermaßen wirksam. Man braucht nicht alle Länder immer zu haben.
Patrick, vielen Dank für die Fragen, und ich hoffe, die Antworten haben was gebracht. Wenn ihr auch Fragen habt, wie gesagt, you're welcome, 0371 77 97 110, die Nummer vom Chaosradio heute Abend. Kleines Päuschen, Frank.
Kleines Päuschen, vielleicht noch ganz kurz. Ihr könnt uns auch eine Mail schreiben. Die lesen wir jetzt hier heute im Studio nicht, aber wenn ihr noch irgendwelche Hinweise habt oder Fragen speziell dazu, schickt die bitte an 95 at chaosradio.ccc.de, also 95 in Zahlen at chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir haben auch eine Mitmachseite auf Wikipedia. Die Mail dazu ist ein bisschen zu lang, aber ihr geht am besten auf chaosradio.ccc.de und da ist die Seite dann auch verlinkt. Und da findet ihr dann auch Hinweise zu den Streams und alles, was ihr über die Sendung wissen müsst.
Genau. Kurzer Tipp noch zum Chaos Computer Club an sich. Weil der feiert seinen 23. Geburtstag und ihr wollt vielleicht, quatsch, ihr wollt, ihr müsst auf der Party dabei sein. Ihr seid dabei. Wir machen da einfach mal so ein Präsens draus. Polizistenpräsens. Ich hab da mal ihren Ausweis bitte. Also ihr seid auf jeden Fall bei der Party dabei. 23 Jahre am 11. September. Wann sonst? Ist klar. Und zwar in der Seabase Infos gibt es natürlich auch unter hier chaosradio.ccc bzw. einfach nur ccc.de. Wir sind gleich wieder da. Thema heute Abend Patente im Chaos Radio. Jetzt. Eine besondere Ausgabe des Blue Moons. Heute Abend, 23 Uhr, haben wir es eine Stunde hier schon gelaufen. Zwei Stunden sind es noch im Chaos Radio Blue Moon vom Chaos Computer Club veranstaltet. Großes Thema heute, deswegen auch viele Menschen im Studio. Thema ist Patente. Da gibt es nämlich eine ganze Menge, ein sehr, sehr weites Feld. Gäste sind Philip Berger, angehender Patentanwalt, Joachim von Oppen, der ist schon Patentanwalt, Fertiger und Robert Gehring, Informatiker an der TU Berlin. Der holt sich gerade einen Kaffee, ist aber gleich wieder da. Und dann noch natürlich der Frank, meine Person der Max und der Harald. Thema Patente, eine Stunde haben wir schon geredet. Jetzt wird es wieder ein bisschen spezieller, beziehungsweise es geht in eine andere Ecke.
Ja, wir haben jetzt sehr viel gehört über Patente und das klingt ja auch theoretisch alles ganz nett und gut. Und das sind die Erfinder, die man fördern muss. Und man muss ihnen irgendwie einen Anreiz geben überhaupt zu erfinden und ihre Erfindungen zu veröffentlichen. Was meiner Meinung nach bislang etwas zu kurz kam, sind die Fragen, wem bringen denn diese Patente was? Oder bringen sie überhaupt etwas? Bringen sie nur dem Erfinder etwas? Nützt das der Volkswirtschaft insgesamt? Das sind Punkte, die nicht aufgegriffen wurden und da würde ich jetzt doch erstmal wieder die Runde an die Experten geben. Wem bringen denn Patente etwas?
Wir Experten müssen jetzt die Patente verteidigen. Ich muss ja zugeben, ob es einen volkswirtschaftlichen Gesamtnutzen gibt oder nicht, das ist wahrscheinlich immer noch umstritten und auch gar nicht so leicht herauszufinden.
Warum überhaupt umstritten?
Weil man natürlich sagen kann, dass das ganze Patentwesen eine ganze Menge Aufwand mit sich bringt. Sehen wir auch selbst. Ich meine, ich selbst lebe davon. Insofern hat es für mich einen positiven Nutzen. Für manche Erfinder natürlich auch, die gut davon leben. Solche Leute wie der berühmte Fischer, der den Fischerdübel erfunden hat, der ist auch aufgrund seiner Patente erreicht gewesen. Und die Dinger nützen ja auch was, meistens zumindest, halten sie auch. Insofern ist das eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, wo es funktioniert hat. Es gibt natürlich auch andere Fälle, wo es nicht so funktioniert hat. Und es gibt natürlich auch auf Seiten der Industrie immer mehr Aufwand, zum Beispiel Patentverletzungen zu vermeiden, Patente zum Gehen und ähnliches. Man könnte auch sagen, es ist nicht nur eine Frage, ob man Patente überhaupt schützen will oder nicht. Ob man so etwas wie eigene Ideen für schutzfähig hält oder sie doch einfach ganz frei lassen will. Es ist natürlich auch eine Frage, wie das ganze System damit umgeht, wie man es durchführt, wie man zum Beispiel sicherstellt, dass eben nicht allzu banale Dinge denn tatsächlich zu einem geschützten Gegenstand kommen.
Nur mal eine Frage, weil wir ja auch immer fragen, wem nützen Patente? Da könnte man ja sagen, Deutschland ist so ein Land, das immer Sachen entwickelt, dass irgendwie Denker, dass die großen Firmen hat, die sollen Sachen entwickeln, die verkaufen sind in der ganzen Welt und die leben eben davon, dass ihre kleinen Dinge auch geschützt werden. Ich erinnere mich an einen Freund meines Vaters, irgendwie mehrfacher Millionär. Mein Vater ist leider kein mehrfacher. Also auf jeden Fall ist der irgendwie total reich, weil der irgendeine üselige Membran erfunden hat, die in ganz vielen Maschinen auf der ganzen Welt eingesetzt wird. Nur er stellt diese Membran her. Und das ist wirklich so was, wo man denken würde, ey, kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein. Hier irgendwie so ein komischer Ring und das soll es jetzt sein. Ja, aber der verdient damit Geld ohne Ende. Und damit ist er natürlich geschützt. Der kann halt seine kleinen Membranen herstellen, ist made in Germany und ist damit reich geworden. Ist das gut oder schlecht?
Möchte ich vielleicht gleich mal eine hacken an der Stelle. Wenn man sich die Statistiken ansieht, also das Argument wäre jetzt gewesen, Deutschland profitiert vom Patentwesen, weil Deutschland so unglaublich viele Patente hat. Könnte man ja meinen. Ja, genau. Wenn man sich die Statistik ansieht, im Jahr 2003 wurden beim Europäischen Patentamt 32.000 Patente aus den USA angemeldet, 24.000 aus Japan und 5.000 aus Deutschland. Zumindest rein quantitativ ergibt sich dadurch ein deutlich schlechtes Verhältnis für Deutschland.
Das ist richtig. Diese Erfahrung mit solch einer Statistik machen wir auch immer wieder. Es gibt natürlich auch Patente, die sind mehr wert und solche Patente, die sind weniger wert. Das hängt damit zusammen, wie schon gesagt, dass der Schutzbereich im Grunde durch diese Ansprüche definiert ist. Und manchmal sind es wirklich nur Nägeligkeiten, Kleinigkeiten, wirkliche Details, die man nicht unbedingt braucht, durch die Patente geschützt werden. Wenn man jedes Detail schützt, bekommt man natürlich viele Patente. Und das ist die Strategie mancher Unternehmen, gerade in Japan und in den USA, weil man dann doch immer mal wieder jemanden findet, der auch diese Kleinigkeit nachmacht und damit Pech gehabt hat. Man kann schon fast sagen, die Patentkultur ist in Deutschland etwas anderes. Das hängt auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass wir ein bisschen mehr Ehrfurcht vor der winderischen Tätigkeit haben, tendenziell. Allerdings glaube ich, dass sich die Statistik auch im Laufe der Zeit ein bisschen angleicht.
Warum hat das eine größere Tradition zum Patentamt zu laufen, in den USA oder in Japan? Sind die so stolz darauf?
Gibt es ein Wettrüsten zwischen den großen Unternehmen, die also meinen, jeder muss das größere Patentportfolio bilden und dass man im Zweifelsfall dann zu einem Cross Licensing-Abkommen kommen kann. Ja, das ist eine Strategie. Also es gibt da denke ich unterschiedliche Punkte. Der eine ist, dass häufig in Investorenkreise, die, wie soll ich sagen, die Fähigkeit zur Innovation eines Unternehmens gemessen wird, wie viele Patentanmeldungen so ein Unternehmen produziert. Ob die Patente dann sinnvoll sind oder ob sie jemals zensiert werden oder ob die irgendwie tatsächlich was Tolles beinhalten, steht überhaupt nicht zur Debatte. Es ist einmal so aus dem Kapitalmarkt heraus der Druck da und auf der anderen Seite diese angesprochene Wettrüsten, wo dann Intel so und so viele Patente hat und Microsoft hat so und so viele Patente. Und wenn dann einer eins vom anderen verletzt, dann kommt es zu einem Cross-Licensing-Abkommen, wo sie dann sagen, naja gut, wir haben 10.000, ihr habt 10.000. Also wir verwenden jeweils die gegenseitig, ohne dass wir Lizenzen an uns zahlen oder wie auch immer. Und je nachdem, wie groß dieser Stapel an Patenten auf der linken oder auf der rechten Seite ist, muss dann halt noch Geld in die eine oder andere Richtung fließen.
Gibt es eigentlich, sag ich mal, irgendwie ein Handhabe, was umgehend damit anbelangt, wenn einer irgendwie sich was patentiert und der hat das halt da im Koffer liegen und benutzt es aber gar nicht? Kann ich dem dann sagen, ja pass mal auf, wenn es nicht benutzt, nach zwei Jahren ist, dann benutzen wir es halt? Oder kann jemand sagen, ich habe etwas patentiert und werde das jetzt 20 Jahre lang nicht machen und 20 Jahre lang wird die Welt das nicht sehen?
Das kann man machen, ja. Und das macht man meistens natürlich nicht, weil das ja Geld kostet 20 Jahre lang. Allerdings gibt es gerade bei manchen größeren Unternehmen schon die Tendenz, auch Schutzrechte, die etwas schützen, was die eigenen Produkte irgendwie gefährden könnte, einfach in die Schublade zu legen. Ich erinnere mich, es gibt Lizenzen zu nehmen und zu sagen, okay, das machen wir jetzt einfach nicht, damit wir weiter unsere Produkte verkaufen können. Aber das ist eine Randerscheinung, die sich für niemanden wirklich lohnt, weil ja alle dafür auch Geld ausgeben müssen.
Ich erinnere mich, war das nicht eine...
Also dieses Argument mit dem Geld ausgeben, selbst wenn es ein paar tausend Euro im Jahr sind und angenommen, also es gibt ja diese Verschwörungstheorien in Bezug auf die Automobilindustrie, dass es irgendwie energiefahrende Motoren gäbe und dass die Pat-ente dafür irgendwo in einer Schublade lägen und dass die nur einfach nicht lizenziert würden oder wie auch immer. Also ich weiß nicht, was da dran ist, aber in jedem Fall...
Aber wenn die Pat-ente in der Schublade lägen, dann würde ja nach anderthalb Jahren bekannt, dass die da liegen, weil das muss man ja bekannt geben, deswegen müsste man es ja eigentlich...
Aber wie dem auch sei, der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, ist eben, dass dieser kleine Betrag zur Aufrechterhaltung eines Patents überhaupt in gar keiner Art und Weise zu vergleichen ist mit dem möglichen wirtschaftlichen Gewinn, den ein Unternehmen aus dem Nicht-Lizenzieren eines solchen Blockade-Patents irgendwie ziehen kann.
Ja, es gibt natürlich immer noch ein Dilemma. Selbst wenn eine Firma jetzt eine große technologische Innovation entwickelt hat. Also eine echte Erfindung, die alle Anforderungen erfüllt und wo alle Experten der Meinung wären, oh, ist so toll, da müssen wir Patent drauf verteilen und so. Das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass die Firma damit genug Anreize hat, das auch zu vermarkten. Wenn diese Firma zum Beispiel groß ist, einen großen Marktanteil hat, dann könnte sie zum Beispiel auf die Art und Weise verhindern, dass andere, die diese Erfindung machen, weniger Marktanteil haben, aber vielleicht aggressiver ein Produkt vermarkten wollen, so ein Produkt vermarkten können. Also ihre eigenen Produkte kriegen damit keine Konkurrenz durch innovative andere Produkte, durch andere Firmen. Das selbe passiert auch in der eigenen Firma. Selbst in der eigenen Firma ist es natürlich so, wenn man ein gut gehendes Produkt hat, was sich verkauft, womit man Profit macht, warum sollte man eigentlich jetzt so viel da investieren, vielleicht eine komplett neue Generation auf den Markt zu bringen? Das ist immer so ein Dilemma. Und das ist also noch nicht wirklich gut gelöst worden. In vielen großen Firmen, also forschungsintensiven Firmen, ist das ein ganz praktisches Problem. Ich weiß es zum Beispiel von Leuten, die mal Anti-Blockiersysteme entwickelt haben, dass aufgrund von bestimmten Nachfragesituationen nach umfallenden Autos ganze Generationen von Forschung quasi auch eisgelegt worden sind, weil einfach nach der Ein-Technologie jetzt eine große Nachfrage generiert worden ist. Damit konnte eine Frage noch abgedeckt werden. Und nach der nächsten Generation, übernächsten Generation war die Nachfrage einmal aus dem Säckering.
Übrigens da ein Hinweis noch. Nur derjenige, der das Patent ja hat, kann es auch in die Schublade legen. Das heißt, der muss erstmal die Erfindung gemacht haben oder irgendwie erworben haben vom Erfinder. Ansonsten geht das ja nicht. Insofern ist das sogar auch ein Anreiz, solche Patente zu schaffen, denn sonst kommt vielleicht jemand anders drauf. Und der ist eben der Schnellere und bringt das auf den Markt und klebt eben vielleicht der gesamten Autoindustrie mit seinem super sparsamen Motor das Wasser ab. Die Möglichkeit besteht ja auch. Und diese Chance gibt ja gerade erst das Patentwesen, weil ansonsten ein Kleiner, der solch eine geniale Idee hat, gar nicht die Chance hat, so ein Auto überhaupt auf den Markt zu bringen. Der würde ja drückt werden von den Großen, die schon da sind.
Genau, deswegen geht er natürlich zu der großen Firma und die nimmt ihm das natürlich auch sofort ab. Also die mehr mit dem Auto, mit dem Sparsamen, die gibt es auch mit irgendwelchen Handys, die automatisch in allen Netzen funktionieren, total sparsam irgendwie zu machen sind und da hat dann irgendein großes Mobilfunkunternehmen oder ein Handyhersteller sofort gesagt, hm, kaufen wir und tschüss.
Aber wenn der Erfinder in diesem Falle zum Beispiel sein Patent überhaupt dahin gebracht hat, wo es dann in die Schublade gelegt wird, hat er sich auch schon ungeschickt verhalten. Ich meine, er hätte mehr draus machen können, das geht ja auch.
Oder er hat viel Geld, damit verdient, das kann natürlich auch sein. Abfindungsweise natürlich. Gut, wem nützen Sie, wem Schadenpatente ist, die Kehrseite der Medaille, wem Schadenpatente?
Also vordergründig natürlich immer denjenigen, der irgendwelche Patente verletzt und der dann plötzlich nicht mehr das machen darf, was er bis dahin gemacht hat, weil er ein Patent an das anderen verletzt. Oder weil er für das, was er bis dahin gemacht hat, Schadenersatz zahlen muss. Das heißt, immer da, wo es schadet, gibt es auch einen, der davon profitiert. Es schadet eigentlich immer demjenigen im Zweifelsfalle, der das Patent nicht hat.
Aber wir haben vorhin mal kurz diesen Vergleich mit dem Urheberrecht. Und das finde ich auch immer ganz spannend, weil es ja in dem Urheberrecht zum Beispiel, was gibt, wenn ich aus Zeitungen zum Beispiel, darf ich zitieren? Hat irgendjemand anders geschrieben? Ich darf das zitieren. Warum kann ich kein Patent zitieren?
Also ich kann in Patentschriften schon andere Patentschriften zitieren, das funktioniert schon. Na das Problem ist, zitieren heißt ja immer, es gibt einen gewissen Umfang an Nutzungsmöglichkeiten, die durch das Verbotsrecht desjenigen, der das Patent hat in dem Falle, nicht eingeschränkt werden können. So darf ich eben zitieren, wobei das im Internet inzwischen aufgrund der neueren Gesetzgebung auch schon anders aussieht. Da kann ich auch nicht mehr so einfach zitieren unbedingt. Aber im Patentrecht ist es eben wesentlich strikter geregelt. Es gibt im Prinzip Ausnahmen, zum Beispiel für die Forschung. Ich darf für die Forschung sozusagen probehalber, für die Weiterentwicklung darf ich ein Patent auch ohne Erlaubnis des Patentinhabers anwenden. Allerdings nur dann, wenn es im nicht gewerblichen Rahmen erfolgt, was also unter Umständen eine schwierige Abgrenzung ist. Und gerade in den USA hat es da einige Fälle gegeben, wo an Universitäten, an Medizingeräten zum Beispiel geforscht worden ist oder im Bereich der Gentechnologie geforscht worden ist. Und dazu muss man bestimmte Verfahren benutzen, die eben patentiert sind. Und das Ganze wurde dann aber vor Gericht als quasi schon gewerblich oder Vorbereitung von gewerblichen Handlungen gewertet. Im Endeffekt wurde es also untersagt. Und es hat in den USA gerade im Bereich der Genforschung also schon massive Konsequenzen, weil Universitäten aus bestimmten Pharma-Forschungsstrichen einfach ausgestiegen sind. Die entwickeln bestimmte Medikamente nicht, weil sie nicht die Kosten tragen können, diese Testverfahren zu lizenzieren. Die sind zu hoch, die Kosten.
Ich stelle mir dann mal vor, irgendein Gerät benutzen. Das Gerät gehört der Firma. Ich habe das irgendwie nachgebaut. Was heißt ein Testverfahren lizenzieren? Was ist das dann zum Beispiel?
Das heißt, dass ich zum Beispiel bestimmte Gensequenzen, um die zu analysieren, brauche ich Testgeräte. Und diese Gensequenzen zu analysieren, mache ich, wenn ich ein Medikament entwickeln will beispielsweise. Und dieses Medikament wiederum kann aufgrund von bestimmten Verträgen von der Uni dann patentgeschützt werden und kann dann seinerseits vermarktet werden. Das heißt, da ist eine Forschungsaktivität dahinter an der Uni und die benutzt eben Geräte. Und um diese Geräte zu benutzen, brauche ich im gewerblichen Bereich eine Lizenz. Und wenn nachher was bei herauskommt, was als Medikament vermarktet werden könnte, bewege ich mich quasi schon in diesem gewerblichen Bereich. Hat jedenfalls das Gerücht so gesagt. Und damit kann ich an der Universität diese Medikamentenforschung, ich muss die Gene, das ist heutzutage in bestimmten Bereichen ebenso, analysieren, mit diesem Gerät nicht mehr machen. Es gibt aber nur einen Hersteller dafür. Und der verlangt eben entsprechende Gebühren. Und damit ist die Universität außen rein.
Es sei denn, wenn ich mal was nicht behörend mache, Grundlage.
Wenn wir gerade schon bei der Gentechnik angekommen sind, wenn es jetzt gerade um Analyseverfahren und nicht um Gentechnik selbst geht, könnte man das Thema ja auch mal anschneiden. Wir sprachen vorhin davon, dass eine Erfindung gemacht werden muss, um ein Patent anzumelden und es muss ein Gebiet der Technik sein. Jetzt gibt es aber Patente auf Gensequenzen von Pflanzen oder Tieren, die tatsächlich so leben. Wer hat denn dieses Tier erfunden?
Das Tier hat keiner erfunden. Das kann höchstens jemand entdeckt haben oder diese Gensequenz. Man bekommt ja auch nicht das Patent für das Gen als solches, sondern man bekommt das Patent dafür, dass man sagt, eine bestimmte Gensequenz wird genutzt, um zum Beispiel eine bestimmte Krankheit zu behandeln oder ähnliches. Also es geht nicht darum, das Gen als solches zu schützen, sondern immer nur eine bestimmte Art des Nutzens des Gens.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass Patente erteilt worden sind, die diese Nutzung sehr wenig eingeschränkt haben. Das heißt, da ist das Patent so erteilt worden, dass es nicht gezielt für eine Krankheitsbehandlung zum Beispiel erteilt worden ist, sondern für eine Klasse von, in Anführungszeichen, Krankheiten. Wenn das Unternehmen jetzt nur ein Medikament gegen eine Krankheit entwickelt und die restlichen Krankheiten, die auch an diesem Gen irgendwie dranhängen, die sind gar nicht lukrativ. Da lohnt es sich gar nicht, Medikamente zu entwickeln für so eine große Firma. Dann haben sie trotzdem das Patent drauf und können also anderen Leuten immer noch verbieten, Medikamente zu entwickeln oder andere Verfahren zu entwickeln, die dann vielleicht nicht medikamentös sind, sondern wie auch immer sind. Und da müssen alle diejenigen, die Interesse daran haben, sowas zu entwickeln, eine Lizenz einholen. Die kann ihnen verwehrt werden, die können sie bekommen vielleicht. Aber sie wissen im Nachhinein nicht, was passiert dann eigentlich, wenn sie doch auf irgendwas stoßen, was dann wiederum lukrativ wird. Wie reagiert denn dann derjenige, der Lizenz gegeben hat? Was steht in dem Vertrag drin? Das heißt, auf diese Art und Weise der recht unscharfen Patentierung, sage ich jetzt mal, entstehen sehr viele Unsicherheiten, Rechtsunsicherheiten und auch Forschungsunsicherheiten. Und man weiß natürlich, da wo Rechtsunsicherheit ist und wo Forschungsunsicherheit ist, da werden Leute nicht unbedingt in die Forschung investieren, sondern dann suchen sie sich was, wo eben mehr Sicherheit herrscht, wo das Risiko geringer ist. Aber das hat natürlich für die Allgemeinheit, hat es Kosten.
Wie ist das, wenn, jetzt habe ich die Frage natürlich, was im Kopf verlor, wie der nur zuhört.
Muss Frank einspringen hier.
Wir sprachen gerade davon unscharfe Patente und große Ansprüche. Vielleicht ist das ein Ansatz jetzt mal über die Qualität von Patentschriften und deren Erfindungshöhe und was auch immer zu sprechen. Also es gibt ja, wie ich schon sagte, auf dem Papier klingt das ganze Patentsystem für mich sehr gut und hat höhere Ziele und wie auch immer und ist alles schön und gut. Aber wenn ich mir dann ansehe, für mich als Entwickler von Software, was es denn im Softwarebereich für Patente gibt. Die Patente, die ich jetzt als Beispiel nenne, sind alles Patente, die vom Europäischen Patentamt oder vom Deutschen Patentamt vergeben wurden. Also ich spreche nicht über die USA, wo die Verhältnisse ja sind wie im Wilden Westen, das wissen wir. Ja, wo also zum Beispiel ein Hersteller ein Patent bekommen hat auf die Kombination eines digitalen Scanners und eines digitalen Laserdruckers zusammen in einem Gehäuse. Das ist dann der digitale Fotografierer. Da frage ich mich dann, ich nehme zwei existierende Geräte, schraube die zusammen in ein Gehäuse und dann bekomme ich ein Patent drauf. Wo ist denn da die Innovation oder das Neue oder wie auch immer? Also für mich ist das trivial.
Ich muss ja zugeben, an der Stelle, ich kenne das Patent nicht, aber an der Stelle würde man sagen, so etwas hat nahegelegen, weil die beiden Bestandteile als solche schon bekannt waren und die einfach nur zusammenzufügen. Das wäre dann eigentlich nicht das, was man unter erfinderischer Tätigkeit versteht, wenn das so ist. Die Schwierigkeit besteht natürlich darin, dass den Nachweis zu erbringen, dass so etwas nahegelegen hat, immer dem Patentamt obliegt. Und die müssen also die entsprechenden Quellen finden, in denen steht, ja Mensch, da ist schon ein Scanner beschrieben und da ist auch schon ein Druckapparat beschrieben, die dann zusammen den Kopierer ergeben. Und das ist die eigentliche Schwierigkeit für das Patentamt, nämlich den Nachweis zu erbringen, dass etwas nahegelegen hat. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, wieso muss denn das Patentamt jetzt nachweisen, dass das Ganze nahegelegen hat? Warum muss nicht der Erfinder nachweisen, dass das eine tolle Erfindung ist? Das ist wieder, wenn man so will, ein Gerechtigkeitsgedanke. Man will es natürlich nicht der Willkür des Patentamtes den Hinz überlassen, ob es sich von der Argumentation des Erfinders überzeugen lässt oder nicht. Sondern man will da wirklich gleiches Recht für alle schaffen und sagen, gut, dann muss das eben das Patentamt immer umgekehrt den Nachweis bringen, dass es keine Erfindung und das ist eine Aufwand und der manchmal auch nicht gelingt. Manchmal findet man einfach nicht die Dokumentation, die Veröffentlichung oder den Gegenstand, den man braucht. Und dann kommt es manchmal dazu, dass Patente erteilt werden, die es vielleicht nicht verdient hätten. Aber dann sind wir alle gefragt. Dann kann man zum Beispiel Einspruch gegen seinen Patent einlegen, was dazu führt, dass man dann selbst die Argumente vorbringen darf, die gegen solch ein Patent sprechen und was dann im Endeffekt dazu führen kann, dass das Patent auch wieder wider rufen wird.
Bei dieser Geschichte wie zum Beispiel Gensequenzen ist es da auch so, dass das Patentamt da eigentlich in der Pflicht gestanden hätte zu sagen, hey, das ist zu pauschal, das hätte eigentlich eingegrenzt werden müssen, kann sowas später dann nachträglich noch passieren?
Das kann passieren, genau im Rahmen dieses Einspruchsverfahrens.
Ja, so ein wichtiger Gedanke dabei ist eigentlich auch, dass man die Rechtshygiene fast schon einfach dem Konkurrenten überlässt. Also so ein sehr weites Patent fordert letztendlich immer einen Einspruch des Konkurrenten heraus. Und von daher ist es eigentlich nicht immer schädlich, wenn das Patentamt jetzt nicht über jede Quelle verfügen kann, weil genau ein Wettbewerber, der sich halt in seiner geschäftlichen Aktivität gestört sieht durch ein Patent, eben genau selber recherchieren wird und dann im Zweifel doch die Prior Art, die eben maßgeblich ist, vorbringen wird.
Aber damit wird natürlich das Gerechtigkeitsargument ein wenig ad absurdum geführt, weil natürlich auch hier wieder ein Willkürelement eingeführt wird. Die einen haben eben als potenzielle Konkurrenten die Möglichkeiten, sozusagen den Gegenbeweis zu führen und die anderen haben eben die Möglichkeiten nicht.
Also es ist kein Willkürargument, es ist mehr ein Ressourcenargument natürlich. Aber ich meine, die Argumente sind auch die, auch der Einsprechende muss eben nachweisen, dass der Gegenstand nahegelegen hat. Das ist nicht willkürlich.
Ja, ein Punkt, den ich vielleicht noch ansprechen möchte, ist, dass es hier um Unternehmen geht in dem Fall zum Beispiel. Mittlerweile gibt es aber eben so ein Phänomen wie Freie Software oder auch Open Source. Wo ich einfach sage, ja, das sind Leute, die entwickeln aus Spaß und Freude irgendetwas. Die kopieren auch nirgendwo. Das ist keine urheberrechtliche Problematik, aber ich kann ja die gleiche Idee haben, wie jemand anderes schon patentiert hat. Beispielsweise hat IBM ein Patent darauf, dass Fenster am Desktop automatisch umarrangiert werden, damit sie sich nicht gegenseitig überlappen. Jetzt schreibe ich irgendein Programm, das die Fenster auch so anordnet, dass sie sich nicht überlappen. Jetzt habe ich dieses Patent verletzt. Wie soll ich jetzt als einzelner Entwickler, oder wie sollen überhaupt diese einzelnen Entwickler ständig die Recherche führen oder ständig anzusehen, was für neue Patente veröffentlicht wurden und gegebenenfalls Einspruch einlegen. Den Einspruch kann ich ja nur für eine sehr kurze, befristete Zeit einlegen. Danach müsste ich eine sogenannte, wenn ich nach diesem Ablauf des Zeitraums noch was dagegen anführen will, muss ich eine Nichtigkeitsklage gegen das Patent führen. Die ist unglaublich teuer und aufwendig. Oder zum Beispiel ein neues Unternehmen kommt in den Markt, oder ein neuer Entwickler oder wer auch immer, um irgendetwas zu tun. Und dieses neue Unternehmen wurde jetzt im Jahr 2004 gegründet. Wie hätte das 1990 schon Einspruch einlegen können gegen irgendein Patent, das damals erteilt wurde? Also das ist für mich immer so ein theoretisches Argument. Und vielleicht kann da vielleicht noch mal jemand aus der Patentanwalzecke Stellung dazu nehmen, wie das aussieht mit Einspruchsfristen, Nichtigkeitsklage und wie schwierig das dann später wird.
Es ist ein zweistufig, wie schon ganz richtig gesagt. Es gibt zum einen direkt in einer Frist, die sich an die Patenterteilung anschließt, die Chance einen Einspruch einzulegen. Der Einspruch ist relativ billig. Das ist das Schöne, die Einspruchsgebühr ist nicht besonders hoch. Man muss allerdings natürlich den Aufwand getrieben haben, das Material gefunden zu haben, was man hinterher braucht, um zu argumentieren, das Ganze hat nahegelegen. Dieses Einspruchsverfahren führt hinter dazu, dass ein Patent von Anfang an für, ja nicht vernichtet, sondern widerrufen wird und von Anfang an nicht gilt. Wenn man diese Einspruchsfrist verpasst, oder zum Beispiel erst nach der Einspruchsfrist in ein Streitgerät, Was ist die Einspruchsfrist? Die ist zum Beispiel gegen ein europäisches Patent, neun Monate Abverteilung des europäischen Patentes. Wenn man diese Frist verpasst, oder der Streit entbrennt erst später, dann kann man nicht die Katzklage erheben. Das ist dann ein streitiges Verfahren, und der Unterlegene muss dann hinter die Kosten zahlen. Aber auch auf diese Weise kann man erreichen, dass das Patent von Anfang an vernichtet erklärt wird, oder eingeschränkt wird, in dem Maße, wie es eben Bestand haben darf.
Eine kostengünstige Variante für dieses junge Unternehmen, das nun meint, dieses Patent kann ich vernichten, aber ich habe leider nicht das Geld für so ein Verfahren. Der kann ja dann einfach, wenn er auf diesem Gebiet selber tätig werden will, einfach mal dem Patentinhaber schreiben, du, das ist alles damals schon alt gewesen, ich will es jetzt auch machen und warum es alt ist, das erkläre ich dir hier. Und dann wird natürlich der Patentinhaber im Zweifel, wenn die Argumente gut sind, auch garantiert nicht eine Klage erheben, weil die wird er dann nämlich verlieren. Und auf die Weise kann man sich dann im Grunde auch ohne Kosten im Zweifel schützen.
Ist halt nur keine Rechtssicherheit.
Man müsste auch ein bisschen vorsichtiger argumentieren, glaube ich, weil wenn das kleine Unternehmen ein potenzieller Konkurrent ist, dann wird sich das große Unternehmen, was vielleicht etabliert ist, schon überlegen, ob es nicht jedenfalls für eine Zeit lang sozusagen den kleinen Konkurrenten noch in so einer Klage irgendwie, die kann man ja ziemlich lange rausziehen, wie man an bestimmten Fällen merkt, sozusagen noch ein wenig hungern lässt. Und dann ist schon die Frage, wie viel Kapitalbasis hat so ein kleines Unternehmen, um durchzuhalten, bevor es sozusagen ohne Produkt am Markt, weil es kann es ohne Patent, also unter dem bestehenden Patentschutz ja nicht vermarkten, ohne Probleme, wie lange hält es kein Unternehmen durch? Und da kann man sagen, dass es nicht so lange durchhalten wird. Also ich würde sagen, es kann zwar vorkommen, dass so eine Variante funktioniert, aber ich habe eher meinen Zweifel, ich habe selbst schon mit Leuten gesprochen, die in so einer Situation waren und die haben alle gesagt, ne, das wird nicht.
Es gibt natürlich übrigens auch immer die Möglichkeit, wenn man relativ ungeschoren wegkommen möchte, im Falle jetzt zum Beispiel dieser sich selbst arrangierenden Fenster auf dem Bildschirm, einfach die Patentverletzung dann eben einzustellen. Und für das bisschen, was man vielleicht verletzt hat, dann notwendigerweise vielleicht ein bisschen Schadensersatz zu zahlen. Meistens ist das dann tatsächlich noch nicht besonders viel. Man muss natürlich dann auf dieses Feature verzichten, aber man muss ja auch anerkennen, dass es jemand anderes erfunden hat.
Ja, Sekunde mal, aber bei sowas wie einem, nehmen wir mal ein Betriebssystem. Ich glaube schon, dass es für Windows, für diese ganzen einzelnen Komponenten, das sind eine ganze Menge, eine Unmenge an Patenten gibt, die alleine nur für dieses Betriebssystem gelten, die sind unüberschaubar. Kann ich überhaupt als normaler Mensch, der jetzt sagt, ich meine klar, es ist utopisch, aber nehmen wir an, ich möchte gerne jetzt ein Betriebssystem anfangen, da kann ich mir doch im Grunde die Hälfte schon klemmen, weil überall auf jedem Weg, den ich beschreiten könnte, sind schon Patentfallen gepflastert, in die ich trampeln könnte quasi.
Das ist richtig, aber es ist natürlich nicht so, dass wirklich jedes dieser kleinen Böhmchen, die in Form dieser Patente angelegt sind, auch hochgehen muss auf der einen Seite. Und wenn sie dann tatsächlich irgendwie zutage treten, kann man ja darauf reagieren in einer Weise, indem man zum Beispiel eine Funktion anders programmiert oder anders auslegt, sodass man das Patent dann umgeht. Das ist doch meistens möglich, denn man darf ja auch nicht vergessen. Die Basisfunktionen, auf denen alle Betriebssysteme basieren, sind häufig schon so alt, dass es dafür gar keinen Patentschutz mehr geben kann.
Gibt es irgendwie sowas wie eine Regelung, also nach dem Motto, das ist ja so wichtig wie die Luft zum Atmen, irgendwas, wo das Patentamt sagt, ne, das ist normal, also ich kann mir jetzt keinen Patent auf Laufen zum Beispiel. Ja, ich habe Laufen erfunden. Gibt es keinen Patent darauf? Also wenn jetzt einer laufen will, dann muss der von mir Lizenzgebühren zahlen. Gibt es sowas Banales oder?
Es gibt in den USA schon Patente, auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise zu laufen.
Also nicht wirklich.
Oder sich auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise die Schuhe zu binden, ist ein Patent in den USA.
Also ob diese Patente sozusagen bestehen würden vor Gericht, wenn der Nachbar, der beim Laufen in dieser patentierten Art und Weise erwischt wird, sozusagen klagt oder verklargt wird, ob das dann Bestand haben würde, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber grundsätzlich, bis es wieder rufen worden ist, besteht das Patent.
Ist das so Monty Python mäßig laufen? Also so die AR-Bahn und Ministry of City Works mäßig?
Ich glaube ja, man muss irgendwie so mit dem Hintern backen und dann das linke Bein hinter das rechte und so. Und dann noch mit dem Arm verdrehen und sowas.
Sowas gibt es übrigens in Europa nicht, nur so zur Beruhigung. Also auch Geschäftsmethoden kann man hierzulande nicht schützen. Und genauso wie zum Beispiel übrigens auch chirurgische oder therapeutische Verfahren als nicht gewerblich gelten und deswegen nicht zu schützen sind. Damit eben jedermann die Therapie bekommen darf, die er braucht.
Der Adam ist am Telefon aus Schwerte, hat eine Frage zum Thema Software. Deine Frage.
Ja, also meine Frage ist, es ist ziemlich schwer zu erklären, aber ich versuche das mal ganz kurz zu machen. Und zwar habe ich die Idee gehabt vor circa zwei Jahren, das ist total trivial eigentlich, das Fire-Options-Projekt per BBB so umzuschreiben, beziehungsweise ohne es umzuschreiben, nutzbar zu machen, über ein Domain in einer Datenbank. Und dies als, sag ich mal, als Foren-Hoff-Ding zu betreiben. Das heißt, es berührt eigentlich das eigentliche per BBB nicht. Es ist ja nur Skripte außerhalb verwendet. Und diese Idee wurde dann nach und nach immer weiter kopiert. Und heute sieht man überall im Internet diese Foren-Hoff-Dings, die auf per BBB passieren. Wie sieht es damit aus? Eigentlich bin ich total gegen Softwarepatenten. Aber wie sieht es aus in diesem Bereich? Ist da überhaupt was machbar?
Was hätte ich davon?
Was hätten andere davon? Und wie sieht es da richtig aus?
Also die Idee hast du gehabt, sowas anzubieten und das andere die Idee quasi übernommen haben, das genau das gleiche zu tun?
Ja.
Dürfen sie auch erstmal, solange man sich selbst nichts geschützt hat. Und ob es überhaupt schutzfähig war, wäre dann ja auch noch zu prüfen gewesen. Aber erstmal ist das natürlich schon der Gedanke, dass alles, was nicht geschützt ist, frei ist. Und das ist ja auch eigentlich gut so. Ich glaube, da sind auch die Software Schaffenden nicht anderer Meinung.
Du willst einen Moment, aber ich glaube, er möchte jetzt gerne wissen, ob er sich das hätte schützen lassen können. Diese Idee, wenn er jetzt sieht, dass ganz viele andere das auch so nachgemacht haben. Oder ist das was, was zu trivial ist oder passt das nicht unter Patente? Ist das wieder was anderes?
Ich denke, das ist nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Da müsste man schon in die Details einsteigen. Und das ist außerhalb dessen, was wir hier machen können in der Sendung.
Wir müssten dann nämlich selbst recherchieren und gucken, was es zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gegeben hat. Und was dann noch neu gewesen ist dem gegenüber. Und das hätte dann den Kern des Schutzes ausgemacht. Und vielleicht ist das neue Feature etwas gewesen, was die anderen jetzt auch gar nicht brauchen. Oder dürfen die das tatsächlich machen? Was sie jetzt sowieso alle tun.
Ich denke aber genau solche einfachen Dinge. Weil nicht jeder hat die Möglichkeit, sich wirklich sehr intensiv mit dem Patenten zu befassen. Ich denke, genau solche Sachen interessieren die einzelnen Programmierer auch.
Das kommt eben ganz drauf an. Von den Details, durch die sich die Erfindung jetzt von dem unterscheidet, was es vorher schon gegeben hat. Also irgendein Detail bei der Umsetzung zum Beispiel.
Gut, Adam, das scheint ein bisschen zu schwierig zu sein. Vielleicht dann doch noch mal eine Recherche wert.
Wir müssten konkreter werden. Und dann wird es auch wieder kompliziert auf anderer Ebene.
Wer ist das gewesen, Adam? Super. Vielleicht kommt ja noch irgendwie so eine Halblösung zustande. So automatisch im Laufe des Blumen ist dann noch die Hälfte Zeit. Ja, danke auch. Wobei, eine Frage finde ich ganz spannend. Jetzt im Hinblick darauf, er hat das ja auch schon länger gemacht. Und jetzt kommen erst die ganzen Leute, haben das nachgemacht. Kann ich rückwirkend ein Patent beantragen?
Nein. In dem Augenblick, wo ich zum Beispiel selbst meine Erfindung veröffentlicht habe, ist sie eröffentlicht geworden. Also Prior Art, Stand der Technik. Und wenn ich dann zwei Tage später auf Detail komme, jetzt will ich es anmelden, bin ich ja sozusagen mir selbst hinterhergelaufen. Denn war das ja schon bevor dem Anmeldetag beim Patentamt öffentlich und kann nicht mehr geschützt werden.
Wobei, ja, gibt's natürlich schon einen Trick. Wenn man, sagen wir mal, irgendetwas in Software erfindet, in Anführungszeichen, was das Patentamt normalerweise patentieren würde. Ob das nun so schön ist oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber die würden das patentieren. Und man hat jetzt das benutzt in einem Programm. Und hat das Programm ganz normal kompiliert und hat es also sowie Programme binär vertrieben werden. Im Paket verpackt und hat es in Laden angeboten und verkauft. Und nach außen hin ist aber nicht sichtbar, dass da sozusagen diese geniale Code-Erfindung drin steckt. Dann kann ich das Programm durchaus schon 5-6 Jahre verkaufen. Und im Nachhinein dann stellt sich heraus, oh, das ist so genial gewesen. Jetzt möchte ich dieses Stückchen, das Programm selber verkauft sich vielleicht schlechter, lohnt sich nicht mehr, aber das Stückchen, was ich hier so habe, das könnte ja noch die große Idee sein. Dann kann ich im Nachhinein immer noch zum Patentamt gehen, weil es als Binärcode vertrieben worden ist. Es ist nicht neuheitsschädlich. Es ist nicht veröffentlicht worden, wenn es im Binärcode vorgelegen hat.
Es ist im Prinzip schon veröffentlicht worden, bloß der Nachweis ist unglaublich schwer, das kann man nicht finden. Oder man muss sehr viel Aufwand treiben, um es zu finden.
Das ist eine Frage, die dahintersteht. Gibt es Firmen, die sagen, ich halte das Ganze lieber geheim, indem ich es sozusagen schiffriere, weil Binärcode wäre ja auch eine Art der Schiffre quasi. Oder gibt es hier Firmen, die sagen, ich mach es lieber so, anstatt dass ich es irgendwie bekannt gebe, weil klar ist, dass es ein Plagiat geben wird, irgendwelche Leute bauen drum herum oder so was?
Ja, zum Beispiel in der Chemie ist das Gang und Gebe. Immer wenn man irgendwelche Substanzen mit einem speziellen Verfahren nur herstellen kann und ich das Verfahren nicht offenbaren muss, indem ich das Medikament zum Beispiel verkaufe, dann ist das natürlich wunderbar. Es kommt keiner auf mein Grundstück, ich mach das alles im Geheimen. Und wenn jemand anders zum Beispiel, das ist umgekehrt auch das Problem, mein Verfahren verletzen würde, ich käme ja auch nicht auf dessen Grundstück und wüsste auch gar nicht so ganz genau. Und ich hätte es sehr schwer, ihm die Patentverletzung nachzuweisen. Da ist zum Beispiel Geheimhaltung immer noch ein sehr gutes probates Mittel.
Eine andere Variante für Geheimhaltung ist natürlich, dass wenn man davon ausgehen muss, dass das Patentamt das nicht anerkennen würde, dann macht es ja Sinn, wenn ich das geheim halte, dann kann ich sozusagen andere davon von der Nutzung fernhalten. Also der Wiederanrufer eben sozusagen es nicht geheim gehalten hat und dann haben es alle nackt gemacht, kopiert, völlig legitim. Kann ich natürlich dadurch verhindern, dass ich es geheim halte.
Und was passiert, wenn ich jetzt jemand bin, der vielleicht auch aus reiner Bushaftigkeit der Meinung ist, dass jemand, der da im Geheimen, in seiner Fabrik, wo eigentlich niemand hinkommt, eines meiner Patente verletzt. Wer ist denn dann, wer hat denn da die Bringschuld? Also kann ich dann sagen, ich würde gerne mal dein Gelände sehen. Dann könnte ich mir auch bei dem abgucken, was der für ein tolles Verfahren entwickelt hat, nur um zu sehen, ach ist doch nicht mein Patent drin. Danke, sorry.
Nee, die Bringschuld hab ich schon. Also wenn ich der Patenthaber bin, dann muss ich nachweisen, dass der andere das verletzt. Achso.
Und das ist der Grund, warum im Prinzip, solange man das stillen Kämmer allein macht oder in einer Firma macht, ohne dass man nach außen sichtbar wird, eigentlich ein relativ geringes Risiko ist. Allerdings zeigt die Praxiserfahrung, dass zum Beispiel ehemalige Angestellte, die gefeuert worden sind und davon wussten, nicht davor zurückschrecken, dann gegebenenfalls zur Konkurrenz zu gehen und dem zu verraten, oh jetzt ist dieses und jenes da. Und wenn der dann mit dem als Zeugen vor Gericht geht und dann in der Regel recht gute Chancen haben, dann entsprechende Ausbegehungen durchzusetzen.
Ich kann natürlich auch die Bringschuld umkehren mit ganz raffig netter Argumentation, wenn ich nämlich nachweisen kann, es gibt eigentlich nur ein Verfahren. Kein Fachmann auf der Welt kennt irgendein alternatives Verfahren, sodass dem ersten Anschein nach, die dasselbe Verfahren, wie ich geschützt habe, verwenden müssen. Dann dreht sich die Beweislast um und die müssen sagen, okay, wir verwenden ein anderes Verfahren.
Patente, Thema heute Abend hier im Chaosradio. Ihr seht, schon nach anderthalb Stunden geht es hoch her, ist aber spannend und bleibt auch spannend. Gleich geht's weiter.
Mein Fritz in Spemberg?
Uhrzeit 23.33. Fritz Info. Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht, wenig Wolken und kein Regen, das bei tiefsten Werten zwischen 9 und 4 Grad. Vorsicht stellenweise gibt es auch Nebel. Morgen wird es schön sonnig und trocken. Rühr da drüben, ja? Mal bitte hier, Nachrichten wichtig. Sonnig und trocken bei Werten zwischen 20 und 24 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
US-Präsident Bush hat Russland jede Unterstützung zur Lösung des Geiseldramas im Kaukasus zugesagt. Bush telefonierte am Abend mit Präsident Putin. Seit heute früh halten bewaffnete Terroristen etwa 300 Kinder, Lehrer und Eltern in einer Schule in der nord-ossetischen Stadt Beslan fest. Die Geiselnähmler fordern den Abzug aller russischen Truppen aus Tschetschenien. Die US-Luftwaffe hat ein Wohngebiet in der irakischen Stadt Fallujah angegriffen. Nach Angaben der irakischen Polizei wurden dabei neuen Zivilisten getötet. Unter den Opfern sind drei Kinder. Das Bundeskabinett hat Änderungen bei den Arbeitsmarktreformen beschlossen. So soll das Arbeitslosengeld II bereits Anfang Januar 2005 ausgezahlt werden. Außerdem dürfen Kinder von Arbeitslosengeld II-Beziehern jetzt bis zu 4.100 Euro besitzen, ohne dass das Geld angerechnet wird. Die Grünenfraktion hat am Abend ihre beiden Vorsitzenden Kathrin Göring-Eckardt und Christa Sager für weitere zwei Jahre im Amt bestätigt. Im Mittelpunkt der zweitägigen Sitzung steht die Überprüfung der Reform des Arbeitsmarktes sowie weitergehende Reformen in der Gesundheitspolitik und der Pflegeversicherung. In Venedig ist das 61. Filmfestival eröffnet worden. Zum Auftakt wird das neue Werk von US-Regisseur Steven Spielberg, The Terminal, gezeigt. Der Film mit Tom Hanks in der Hauptrolle läuft außerhalb der Konkurrenz. Insgesamt bewerben sich in diesem Jahr 21 Filme um den goldenen Löwen. Der Verkehr Fritz mit einer Meldung A24 Schwerin Richtung Berlin zwischen Pritzwalk und Wittstock-Dosse ist der rechte Fahrstreifen nach einem Unfall blockiert. Ansonsten gute Fahrt für euch.
Fritz präsentiert im September The Darkness, Motorhead und Apokalyptica live bei Werner das Rennen auf dem Eurospeedway Lausitz Kid Alex live in Cottbus im September Max Herre das exklusive Radiokonzert live in den Fritz Studio und das Fritz Popkom Radio drei Tage lang mit den fantastischen vier fettes Brot und den Beatstakes live in der Deutschlandhalle. Fritz im September.
Mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
Kurz nach der Halbzeit, noch knapp eineinhalb Stunden Zeit zu talken. Heute zum Thema Patente im Studio, wirklich bunch of people könnte man so sagen. Philipp Berker, angehender Patentanwalt der Joachim von Oppen, der ist es schon, nämlich Patentanwalt Robert Gehring, Informatiker von der TU Berlin, Frank und Harald vom Chaosradio. Und meine Person, der Max. Also insgesamt, wer mitgezählt hat, richtig, sechs Stück, ihr seid noch wach. Patente, wie gesagt, das Thema. Und ihr könnt auch anrufen unter 0331 77 97 1 1 0 und zum Thema beitragen oder vielleicht sogar Fragen stellen. Wenn man die Profis schon mal was fragen kann, dann sollte man das natürlich auch tun. Zunächst mal am Telefon ist der Bernhard aus Tempelhofen, Name Bernhard.
Was ich ansprechen wollte, ist ein Problem, was ich doch für ziemlich eklatant halte. Und zwar für jedes zugesprochene Patent. Sozusagen bekommt das Patentamt ja Geld. Also sie kriegt Geld dafür, wenn Patent zugesprochen wird und nicht, wenn es abgelehnt wird. Und ob da nicht sozusagen die Moral sinkt, dann sich stark mit so einem Patentantrag auseinanderzusetzen.
Also erstmal kriegt das Geld sowohl für jede Patentanmeldung, egal ob die hinterher zur Patenterteilung kommt oder nicht. Es lebt natürlich etwas besser von Jahresgebühren, die dann für nur länger verteilte Patente bezahlt werden. Aber das ist glaube ich nicht die eigentliche Motivation.
Also ich meine, ich habe in der CT darüber einen Artikel gelesen, dass dadurch, wie sie schon gesagt hat, dass nicht so danach geschaut wird, dass vom Patentan selbst meint, dass da falsche Patente oder zu weite Patente ausgeteilt werden.
Also du meinst, dass das Patentamt selbst ein Interesse daran hat, möglichst viele Patente zu machen? Wer kriegt denn das Patentgeld oder die Gebühren für so ein Patent, wo bleibt es denn eigentlich oder was für eine Rechtsform hat überhaupt dieses Patentamt? Also das Europäische Patentamt finanziert sich tatsächlich aus diesen Gebühren, nimmt aber aufgrund der tatsächlich zahlreichen Patente, die jedes Jahr teilt werden, gehalten werden, so viel Geld ein, dass es sogar vor einiger Zeit die Gebühren gesenkt hat. Von daher halte ich es eigentlich für ziemlich abwegig, jetzt dem Amt zu unterstellen, dass die gerne viele Patenteerteilen möchten, weil dann hätten sie auch die Gebühren nicht senken müssen. Und dann muss man natürlich auch die Frage stellen, wer soll sich denn das Geld dann eigentlich in die Tasche stecken? Der Präsident vom Amt oder gibt es dann freiwerener Cafeteria? Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich nicht so wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ne, das ist klar, aber ich möchte jetzt auch niemanden zu nahe treten, aber auch sozusagen von den Leuten, die Patente bearbeiten praktisch, dass sie sich da... Also inwiefern sind die denn kontrolliert oder irgendwie?
Da gibt es ein Leistungssystem, aber der einzelne Patentprüfer verdient jetzt nicht für ein erteiltes Geld extra. Der kriegt da keine Prämie, super, hast du ihn am Patent erteilt, sondern der hat eventuell natürlich nicht das Interesse, sich jahrelang mit einem Anmelder zu streiten und möchte vielleicht das Patent ein bisschen schneller zu den Akten legen, aber dass da irgendwie ein Prinzip gegeben wäre, glaube ich nicht.
Ein Kernproblem gibt es schon, muss man fairerweise sagen, nämlich das Zurückweisen an der Patentanmeldung ist für den Prüfer ein bisschen mehr Aufwand und Arbeit, weil er den Nachweis bringen muss, dass das Ganze nahegelegen hat, als einen Patent einfach anzuerkennen. Und insofern kann er, wenn er Patente immer nur erteilt, ein paar mehr Fälle erledigen. Und das wird von ihm schon erwartet. Aber das ist eigentlich die einzige Motivation. Er macht sich einfach weniger Arbeit, wenn er Patente einfach erteilt. Wobei meine Erfahrung, da muss ich einfach die Ehre des Patentamtes in der meisten Prüfer retten, die ist, dass die Prüfer schon ein echtes Interesse daran haben, wirklich nur solche Patente zu erteilen. Auch ein persönliches Interesse. Quasi sowas wie einen Berufsethos, die auch wirklich auf einer erfinderischen Tätigkeit beruhen. Und deswegen geben sie sich große Mühe, Patente auch zurückzuweisen.
Als sportlichen Ehrgeiz oder?
Können die denn zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden, wenn sie Patente übersehen haben? Oder sind die da gänzlich aus der Pflicht genommen? Also wenn die es irgendwie übersehen haben, es gab schon irgendwas, dann ist es halt sorry. Ist so gelaufen.
Das ist so. Das ist de facto so. Dann muss eben die Öffentlichkeit einspringen, zum Beispiel im Rahmen des schon diskutierten Einspruchs oder Nichtigkeitsvertragens.
Also im Prinzip wie ein Schiedsrichterauto.
Den gab es halt nicht.
Man muss auch sagen, dass in den USA die Situation schon ein bisschen anders aussieht. Da ist quasi das Patentamt als Profit Center eingerichtet. Und da ist es tatsächlich so, dass die mit den Einnahmen aus den Patentanmeldungen Gewinn machen sollen. Und wenn die also anfangen sozusagen, Wörtersachen abzulehnen, dann würden ja dann ihre Arbeitszeit verloren quasi und die Jahresgebühren der Patente werden einfach nicht eingenommen. Auf die Art und Weise würden die auf Dauer Verlust machen. Und so dass in den USA die Anreize quasi viele Patente zu erteilen und dann die qualitative Patentprüfung und zweifelsfallige Gerichten zu überlassen, schon deutlich größer sind, als sie meinetwegen in Europa aussehen.
Also praktisch dann jedes Patent erstmal schauen, ob dann irgendwer es anzweifelt und dann sollen die es halt zweifeln. Aber wir geben jetzt erstmal dem Patentanträgerrecht sozusagen.
Genau, weil wenn das Patent erst mal erteilt wird, dann kriegt das Patentamt die Einnahmen aus den Anmeldegebühren und aus den Jahresgebühren. Und wenn es jetzt so unrecht erteilt worden ist, dann muss das in der Regel vor Gericht irgendwie entschieden werden.
Aber auch in den USA haben die Prüfer den öffentlichen Auftrag, nur solche Patente zu verteilen, die wirklich auch auf öffentlicher Tätigkeit in Ventures Lab beruhen. Und auch da nehmen die Prüfer in der Regel ihre Aufgabe ernst. Das muss man denen auch zuerkennen. Auch wenn dann vielleicht ein gewisses gegenläufiges Interesse auch vorhanden ist. Da wohnen eben zwei Seelen in deren Brust. Aber Patentprüfer verstehen sich meistens doch als Vertreter der Öffentlichkeit und haben deswegen das Interesse, möglichst wenig Patente zu verteilen. Das nächste einmal, weil sie nämlich die Öffentlichkeit vor unnützten Schutzrechten bewahren wollen.
Werner, hast du die Frage beantwortet so weit?
Ja, mir ist jetzt noch eine zweite Sache eingefallen, also jetzt zum Gespräch. Und zwar, wie ist es, wenn jetzt praktisch nachträglich, meinetwegen durch so ein Nichtigkeitsantrag oder sowas war das wohl, wenn dann so ein Patent aberkannt wird, kriegt man dann seine Patentgebühren oder wie das ist zurückgezahlt?
Nein, das Risiko trägt der Patentinhaber. Insofern ist das natürlich immer ein gewisses Risiko. Also der kann wirklich ganz auf die Schnauze fallen, dazwischen durch ein tolles Patent gehabt, viel Geld dafür ausgegeben und im Ergebnis nichts davon.
So, und zum Thema Patente, die vernichtig erklärt werden, hatte vorhin auch der David schonmal angerufen, der war rausgeflogen, ist aber jetzt wieder da. Hallo David.
Hi, und zwar geht es darum, wenn ein Patent vernichtig erklärt wird, und die Firma, die das Patent innehatte, dafür Lizenzgebühren bekommen hat, die werden dann zurückgezahlt?
Nein. Auch nicht, auch nicht. Das ist sozusagen verlorenes Geld, das ist das Risiko, was man eingeht. Ich meine, das ist zum Beispiel Rechtssicherheit, die sich der Lizenznehmer über die ganze Zeit erkauft hat. Der hat sich auch das Nichtigkeitsverfahren erspart. Bitte? Er hat sich auch das Nichtigkeitsverfahren erspart. Der Lizenznehmer, ich meine, der die Lizenzgebühren gezahlt hat, der wusste ja, der war ja schon mit dem Patentinhaber in einem Boot und brauchte deswegen nichts dagegen zu unternehmen.
Toll, ich habe also Geld dafür bezahlt, dass ich das Geld für das Gerichtsverfahren nicht bezahlen muss.
Super. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht von vornherein gesagt, dass man so ein Nichtigkeitsverfahren gewinnt. Also die Rechtssicherheit, dass man auf jeden Fall nicht belangt werden kann aus diesem Patent, weil man nämlich die Zustimmung des Patentinhabers hat, die gewinnt man zum Beispiel über so einen Lizenzvertrag und für den muss man in der Regel auch ein bisschen was bezahlen, damit man diese Zustimmung bekommt.
Gerade aus der Perspektive einer kleinen Firma zum Beispiel kann es sehr viel Sinn machen, sich nicht auf so eine Milchgeheizklage einzulassen, weil da muss man unter Umständen viel Geld investieren und man weiß nicht, wen man bei rauskommt. Sondern eher auf das Angebot einzugehen, ok, wir bieten euch hier eine Lizenz an, selbst wenn wir wissen, dass es vielleicht nicht ganz sauber ist, die ganze Geschichte, aber wenn ihr die Lizenzgebühren zahlt, dann ist hier sozusagen gemeinsamer Vorteil, ihr könnt euer Produkt vermarkten, wir haben die Lizenzgebühren, alle sind zufrieden.
Und wenn jetzt beispielsweise eine böse große Firma mit den ganzen Patenten kommt, zum kleinen Unternehmen und sagt, ihr benutzt irgendein Verfahren, das wir patentiert haben, und die kleine Firma erreicht im Nachhinein, dass dieses Patent vernichtig erklärt wird.
Dann verliert die böse große Firma das ganze Verfahren, nicht nur das Nichtigkeitsverfahren, sie verliert also ihr Patent, sondern sie verliert auch den Verletzungsstreit, weil das Patent nämlich von Anfang an vernichtig erklärt wird.
Ja, aber das kleinere Unternehmen müsste ja dann für eine gewisse Zeit das Verfahren nicht benutzen.
Na gut, wenn sie es gar nicht benutzt hat, die kleine Firma, dann hat sie auch nichts verletzt. Dann kann sie auch nicht belangt werden. Wenn sie es benutzt hat, dann geht sie natürlich das Risiko ein, wenn sie den Streit verliert, dann hängt er dafür, nachhinein Schadensersatz zu zahlen, was aber bei geringer Benutzung auch nicht so schlimm ist. Das Schlimmste für die kleine Firma ist, dass sie den Streit durchhalten muss natürlich.
Was noch passieren kann, ist natürlich, dass das Gericht in einer einstfälligen Verfügung anordnet, dass die kleine Firma sozusagen die Verletzung einstellt. Und dann kann die kleine Firma in der Zeit, während das Verfahren läuft, und vielleicht gewinnen sie es sogar, aber in dieser Zeit können sie das Verfahren nicht benutzen. Sie können ein Produkt nicht vermarkten, wo das Verfahren benutzt wird usw. Und das heißt, denen brechen die Einnahmen weg. Das kann schon passieren. Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht ein Regelfall, aber es kann schon mal passieren.
Und können sie diese Einnahmen dann irgendwie dafür Strafe verlangen?
Also in den USA gibt es dann schon die Möglichkeit, dass dann im Nachhinein quasi das Gericht festlegt, dass diese einstfällige Anordnung aufgrund von sozusagen den vorgelegten Behauptungen des großen, bösen Unternehmens ergangen worden ist. Und die haben das Ganze böswürdig gemacht. Und dann kann das kleine Unternehmen wiederum auf dem Weg der Zivilrechtsklage von großen Unternehmen sozusagen für die Bösgläubigkeit einen Schadensersatz einfordern. Dann haben sie ein nächstes Verfahren am Hals. Und müssen dafür das Geld wieder aufbringen. Also, das ist nicht so einfach.
Viel Spaß bei was auch immer du vorhast. Aber Joachim, weil du immer sagst, wenn da irgendwie noch nicht viel gemacht worden ist, dann kostet das auch nicht viel. Hast du irgendwie mal Beispiele, was so eine Verletzung kostet, wenn man wie viel gemacht hat?
Ja, zum Beispiel hat man irgendein Produkt, damit hat man einen Umsatz gemacht von insgesamt 10.000 Euro. Das ist zwar auch schon eine ganze Menge, aber davon ist natürlich nicht alles Gewinn. Und wenn man jetzt den Schadensersatz versucht zu berechnen, dann macht man das häufig, indem man sich überlegt, was hätte denn eigentlich dieser Patentverletzer an Lizenzgebühren zahlen müssen, wenn er ganz brav gewesen wäre und um Erlaubnis gefragt hätte. Und das liegt dann zum Beispiel in der Größenordnung zwischen 1 und 5 Prozent von diesen 10.000 Euro, die dann überhaupt nur als Streitsumme im Raum stehen. Über mehr wird sich dann nicht gestritten. Also nicht etwa über den gesamten Umsatz, sondern nur um diesen Bruchteil, den man sonst hätte, in Form von Lizenzgebühren zahlen müssen.
Das ist bei einem Patent. Jetzt verletze ich vielleicht gleich 10 oder 15. Dann sehe ich aber nicht mehr nur 5 Prozent, sondern dann sehe ich auf einmal 50 Prozent.
Nee, das ist nicht so. Das ist nicht so. Wenn zum Beispiel ein großer 5 Patente hat, die alle gleichermaßen verletzt werden, dann geht man auch davon aus, dass die Lizenz, die der kleine Verletzte hätte nehmen müssen, vom Großen erteilt hätte werden müssen. Dann wäre die Lizenzgebühr vielleicht nicht üblicherweise 2-3 Prozent, sondern vielleicht 4 Prozent. Für alle zusammen. Für alle 5 oder 10 Patente zusammen.
Wobei man natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen differenzieren muss. Das Ganze gilt wahrscheinlich jetzt für irgendwelche Maschinen und so weiter, ohne Probleme. Wenn man jetzt den Vertrieb von, sagen wir mal, Software im Internet in Betracht zieht, wo es also schon mal schnell passieren kann, ok, da werden jetzt Downloadzahlen von ein paar 100.000 oder vielleicht sogar Millionen erreicht für irgendein Softwareprogramm. Und da steigt irgendein Verschlüsselungsverfahren drin. Und derjenige, der es anbietet, hat unter Umständen noch nicht mal wirklich Geld damit verdient. Andererseits kann der Hersteller, dem das Patent gehört, damit auch kein Geld mehr verdienen, weil die andere Software ist ja jetzt schon raus und so weiter. Er macht also Verlust dafür. Wie sieht es eigentlich dann aus in dem Falle?
Das gibt es auch. Es gibt auch die Schadensberechnungsart des entgangenen Gewinns. Dazu muss aber, und das ist das große Problem auf Seiten des Patentinhabers, dazu muss der nachweisen, dass ihm wirklich dieser Gewinn entgangen ist. Das heißt, der muss nachweisen, dass all diejenigen, die jetzt einfach diese Software runtergeladen haben, diese Software auch bei ihm gekauft hätten. Und dieser Nachweis ist natürlich ganz schön schwierig.
Gibt es Subpräzedenzfälle? Also gerade in dem Bereich, weil gerade weil es so schwammig ist, haben Leute natürlich immer genau Angst vor solchen Situationen. Wenn die einfach die besseren Anwälte verbrauchen, um das durchzusetzen, dann ist es klar, wer gewinnt, wenn da eine dicke Firma dahinter steckt natürlich.
Na gut, ich meine auch der beste Anwalt kann natürlich zum Beispiel nicht ohne weiteres jetzt durchgegegen laufen und die Leute zählen, die die Produkte tatsächlich gekauft hätten. Das ist wirklich schwer, diesen Nachweis zu bringen. Und ich kenne auch keinen Präzedenzfall dieser Art. Ich weiß nur, dass eben gerade deswegen meistens diese Schadensersatzberechnung.
Gemäß Litenzgebühren einfach... Im Bereich des Urheberrechts gibt es zum Beispiel diesen riesigen Präzedenzfall Musikindustrie. Da wird ganz viel Musik runtergeladen und da wird halt versucht zu belegen, hat das der Musikindustrie geschadet? Ja oder nein? Und die verlangen zum Beispiel in den USA horrende Summen, wobei das auf zivilrechtlichen Parkett geschieht. Gibt es da auch noch mal den Unterschied, dass auf zivilrechtlichen Basis nochmal eine andere Klage angestrengt werden kann?
Alles, was wir hier besprechen, findet tatsächlich auf zivilrechtlicher Ebene statt. Einzig der Widerruf des Patentes. Der ist dann eben auch quasi zivilrechtlich, aber in Sonderrecht nämlich vor dem Bundespatentgericht zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich wollte gerade nochmal einspringen, nachdem wir jetzt wieder bei Softwarepatenten sind. Wenn ich jetzt zwischen Unternehmen spreche und von Unternehmen, die Produkte verkauft haben, wo ich Verkaufszahlen nachweisen kann und so weiter, das ist ja alles noch schön und gut. Schaue ich mir jetzt aber zum Beispiel die Freisoftware-Open-Source-Szene an, kann auch ganz konkret jetzt mich als Beispiel nehmen. Ich hab mit am Linux Kernel entwickelt, hab wesentliche Teile des Firewallings dort geschrieben. Und der Linux Kernel wird ja, das kann man vielleicht schätzen, 10, 20, 30 Millionen Mal, wie auch immer, weltweit eingesetzt auf Systemen. Und es würde jetzt sich herausstellen, dass irgendwo ein Patent verletzt worden. Ich kann ja die Zahl überhaupt gar nicht ermitteln der Leute, die das verwenden. Ich hab auch gar kein Geschäft damit gemacht. Ist es dann gewerbsmäßig, was ich getan habe? Ist es eine Vorbereitung einer gewerbsmäßigen Tätigkeit? Woran würde ich überhaupt da Dinge festmachen wollen? Es passt einfach nicht.
Also grundsätzlich wird eigentlich Internetvertrieb als gewerblich eingestuft, bzw. entfällt durch den Internetvertrieb kein Schutz, der bei nicht gewerblicher Nutzung bestehen würde. Im privaten Bereich, nicht gewerblich, sind manche Dinge privilegiert. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich das ins Innere stelle, wird der private Bereich des nicht gewerblichen überschritten. Und das Ganze ist nicht mehr privilegiert. Ich mach mich also grundsätzlich da schadensersatzpflichtig. Und insofern müsste man zweifelsfrei davon ausgehen, dass es gewerblich ist.
Kann ich denn zum Beispiel mich selber absichern, indem ich sage, ich möchte gerne, dass diese Software, die ich da verteile, nur zu privaten, nicht gewerblichen Zwecken genutzt wird. Alles andere ist strafbar. Kann ich das machen und bin damit aus dem Schneider, wenn eine andere Firma dann nicht sagen kann, sie hat da einen Verlust mitgemacht, weil sie für gewerbliche Zwecke das ganze Ding...
Also grundsätzlich kann ich ja als Urheber selbst die Lizenzbedingungen bestimmen, unter denen mein Werk quasi vertrieben wird und genutzt werden darf. Ich kann sagen, also meine Software darf nur in Verbindung mit folgender Espressomaschine benutzt werden, die leider hier nicht auf dem Schreibtisch steht. Und dann muss derjenige sich dran halten. Wenn nicht, dann verletzt er die Lizenzbestimmungen, die ich ihm gegeben hab. Und dann könnte ich ihn wegen Scharnalters verklagen und so weiter. Aber die Frage ist, ob nicht allein schon durch den Vertrieb dann wiederum bestimmte... Also es gibt ja im Internet extra Distributionsrechte mit der neuen Urheberrechtsrichtlinie von der EU. Und damit ist sozusagen der Vertrieb selber schon ein eigenständiges Recht unter Umständen. Und dann könnte es schon sein, dass das wiederum in den gewerblichen Bereich reinfällt. Also da wird es ganz haarig.
Und irgendwie sowas wie... Ich war zu doof und wusste das nicht. Sowas zählt in dem Bereich leider nicht.
Das zählt nicht.
Nee, also wenn ich mir irgendwie ein kleines Programm geschrieben hab, was für mich eine bestimmte Sache erledigt, und ich denke ach, Mensch das ist ja schön, ich stell das auch mal anderen Usern zur Verfügung. Wenn ich damit irgendwas verletze, bin ich dran. Richtig.
Und da sieht man schon wieder dieses krasse Missverhältnis, das entsteht, dass Patente immer große Firmen bevorzugen. Weil eine große Firma kann sich einen eigenen Stab an Patentanwälten leisten, die bei jeder kleinen neuen Entwicklung recherchiert und versucht herauszufinden, wo vielleicht Patente verletzt werden. Nur mal vielleicht als auch ein paar statistische Zahlen dazu. Also beim deutschen Patent- und Markenamt liegen 380.000 Patente insgesamt vor. Das ist der Bestand. Und es werden, Stand 2003, 58.000 neue Patente im Jahr zur Anmeldung eingereicht. Also man muss da wirklich selbst in dem jeweiligen spezifischen Fachgebiet ganz schön enorm nachsehen, was da an Patentschriften irgendwo drinsteht. Und dann muss ich auch noch verstehen können, was in diesen Patentschriften drinsteht, weil die sind ja nicht irgendwie technisch formuliert, sodass es ein Entwickler verstehen könnte. Wir haben da ein schönes Beispiel.
Ja, ich hab mal ein bisschen was rausgesucht aus einer beliebigen Patentanmeldung. Und ich lese jetzt gerade mal vorher. Vielleicht versteht ihr das, wenn jemand versteht, was da mit gemeint ist, dann soll er ruhig mal anrufen.
033 877 9110 ist das.
Die bevorzugte Ausführung des Gerätes mit einem nicht flüchtigen Speicher enthält in diesem gespeicherte Informationen, die vorzugsweise in komprimierter Form bereitgehalten werden, um nach dem Einschalten des Gerätes einmalig in dekomprimierter Form in ein oder mehrere zugeordnete Segmente des Arbeitsspeichers kopiert zu werden, kopiert und bis zum Ausschalten des Gerätes unverändert bereit gehalten zu werden. Diese Ausführungsvariante hat den Vorteil, dass ein langsamerer und bei Kompressionen der im nicht flüchtigen Speicher enthaltenen Informationen kleinerer nicht flüchtiger Speicher eingesetzt werden kann. Durch Dekompressionen und Kopieren dieser Information in den Arbeitsspeicher können diese Beschränkungen des nicht flüchtigen Speichers vorteilhaft ausgeglichen werden. Also Leute, was ist das? Was wird da beschrieben?
Alter Vater!
Weißt doch, dass ich Frank einfach nicht mehr mitnehmen soll auf diese Veranstaltung. Wunderbar! Wir werden jetzt gleich einfach nochmal kurz telefonieren. Ihr habt nämlich auch schon angerufen. Vielleicht nicht dazu. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ilya oder auch Michael das jetzt beantworten können, aber ihr hört auf jeden Fall das Chaosradio. Wie gesagt, Chaosradio noch eine Stunde. Demnach, weil wir schon um 10 Uhr angefangen haben, bis 1 Uhr heute Nacht. Philipp Robert und Joachim sind Gäste, zwei Patentanwälte, ein angehender, ein praktizierender Fertiger und ein Informatiker, so wie Frank Harald und meine Person vom Chaos Computer Club zum Chaos Radio heute Abend. Thema Patente und am Telefon ist erstmal, wenn wir ihn nicht schon verscheucht haben, ich hoffe, er musste nicht zu lange warten, der Michael. Hallo Michael.
Ja, schon guten Abend, hallo.
Ich musste nicht zu lange warten, ging noch.
Wunderbar.
Und zwar, weil ich fragen wollte, ich bin auch ziemlich neu so in dem ganzen Internetgewerbe und ich habe erst mal einen kleinen Forum angefangen und zwar eJoker.de und ich wollte fragen, wie das aussieht mit Patenten mäßig, wenn User, Erfahrungsberichte, das ist ein Spielforum, Erfahrungsberichte und so weiter, Testberichte von sich aus, von Spielen da rein, setzen und so weiter, ob man sich das auch schützen lassen kann.
Ob du dir was schützen lassen kannst? Die Berichte von den Sachen, die andere Leute da reingeschrieben haben?
Genau.
Na, die haben ja ein Urheberrecht automatisch erworben, indem sie das da reingeschrieben haben, das heißt, die haben wahrscheinlich automatisch das Urheberrecht, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Die Leute, nicht ich.
Die haben das ja geschafft.
Und wie sieht das aus, wenn Leute da einen Bericht reinschreiben, stimmen die doch damit ein, dass der Bericht dann zu Chaos wird, oder?
Genau. Die haben ja ein Urheberrecht geschaffen mit ihrem Bericht und die müssen natürlich die Genehmigung erteilen, dass die das auch veröffentlichen dürfen. Und deswegen müssen die diese Erklärung abgeben, dass sie damit einverstanden sind, dass das veröffentlicht wird.
Aber die Urheberrechte von den Berichten gehören dann Chaos?
Nein, die Nutzungsrechte, da muss man ganz fein unterscheiden. Das Urheberrecht, das liegt immer beim Urheber. Das kann er gar nicht verkaufen, anders als ein Patent zum Beispiel. Aber er kann Nutzungsrechte vergeben, jetzt ist es richtig.
Und wahrscheinlich steht in den Verträgen drinnen, dass diejenigen, die diesen Kommentar schreiben, ein nicht exklusives Nutzungsrecht an Chaos vergeben und dann dürfen die das da abdrucken.
27 aus Potsdam.
Ja, hallo.
Auch eine Webseitenfrage.
Ja, genau. Ich hatte eigentlich eine Frage zum Urheberrecht. Und zwar hatte ich das Problem, dass mir jemand Inhalte meiner gewerblichen Webseite auf seine Seite verlinkt hat, sodass meine kompletten Inhalte samt meiner Fotos der Texte, die ich gestaltet habe, auf seiner Seite unter seiner Adresse erschienen sind. Die Frage ist, wie könnte ich den jetzt belangen? Weil er hat ja im Prinzip keine Nutzungsrechte gehabt, sondern halt nur das Ding letztendlich geklaut. Hab ich gemacht, aber die kommen halt nicht weiter. Also ich suche jetzt einen Ansatzpunkt dafür, wie man da weitermachen kann. Also die Sache ist die, also wir haben ihn jetzt halt darauf hingeht, erstmal auf Unterlassung verpflichtet, das hat er dann auch gemacht, aber letztendlich ist es so, dass er letztendlich die Sachen, wo wir uns echt Mühe gegeben haben, wo wir Sachen recherchiert haben, auch im Internet geguckt haben, dass wir jetzt nicht irgendwo einen Satz haben, der irgendwo genauso drin steht, dass es halt wirklich unsere Sache ist, für sich genutzt hat und das halt auch gewerblich und auch publiziert hat. Gibt es da irgendwie einen Ansatzpunkt, wo man sagen kann, ey, der hat Urheberrecht verletzt, dafür gibt es halt den und den Schaden, oder da komme ich halt nicht weiter.
Anwalt. Ja, also wir können hier keine Rechtsverwaltung leisten und es geht auch ganz eindeutig um die Urheberrechtsproblematik. Das tut mir leid.
Fühlen wir uns jetzt nicht als...
Ist denn überhaupt ein Schaden entstanden?
Na ja, eigentlich materiell ist es nicht nachweisbar. Also ich weiß halt auch nicht, was hat denn Aufträgen mit unserer Seite letztendlich gezogen. Das ist halt nicht nachvollziehbar.
Und da liegt meistens das Problem, ohne da jetzt ins Detail gehen zu wollen.
Inwiefern hat er denn überhaupt gewerblich einen Umgang damit getrieben? Das wäre ja die Frage. Also was hat er gewerblich daran für einen Gewinn gehabt? Weil du sagst, was er für Aufträge gezogen habe.
Na das ist so, dass er im Prinzip unsere Seite fast komplett, also von den Inhalten her kopiert hat. Er hat sogar unser Anfrageformular kopiert. Leicht verändert dahingehend, dass er halt nur seine E-Mail-Adresse und seine Fax-Nummer reingeschrieben hat.
Clever.
Und hat damit auch einen ganz guten Monat, einen ganz guten Traffic gehabt. Dahingehend, weil die Seiten immer wieder auf uns verlinkt waren. Das heißt, wenn der User auf seiner Seite war, ist er eigentlich auf unserer Seite gewesen, hat er dort unseren Traffic genutzt. Letztendlich nur. Das ist halt aber eben bei unserem Paket so dick gewesen, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir mussten jetzt nicht mehr Traffic zahlen oder so. Sondern eben, er hat einfach nur unsere Inhalte genutzt. Natürlich unser geistiges Eigentum, sag ich mal.
Aber ich bin mich wundert, dass der Anwalt nichts erreicht hat. Also, ein Anwalt für sich klingt deswegen ein ziemlich klarer Fall von Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Unterlassung hat er immerhin schon mal hingekriegt, habe ich jetzt rausgehört.
Und wenn eben kein nachweisbarer Schaden da ist, dann wird auch der Anwalt keinen Schadensersatz rausholen, sondern dann bleibt es eben dabei.
Ja, seine Unterlassungserklärung ist ja normalerweise eigentlich auch strafbewehrt. Also er unterschreibt da ja, dass er gegen eine Strafe, also eine Strafandrohung, eben das unterlassen wird. Und im Grunde ist in dem Moment ja auch der Schaden gegeben, wenn er so weiterhin diese Inhalte darstellt, fällt eben genau diese Vertragsstaffer an.
Soweit ich weiß, muss sie sogar strafbewehrt sein, die Unterlassungserklärung.
Ja, das war dann irgendwie mit 15.000 Euro irgendwie stand da was drin.
Genau, das ist üblich.
Genau. Aber letztendlich so was sieht man halt nur, sag ich mal, wenn der jetzt auch das weiterhin hätte genutzt.
Genau, wenn er es nochmal macht, dann genau.
Aber ansonsten ist es halt nur so, dass die Anwälte daran verdienen an so einer Geschichte.
Das kann leider leicht passieren.
Ach, das heißt eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen mal als Autonomal-User letztendlich mir von MediaMarkt auf die Seite verlinke und damit einen Monat ganz gut was schaffe, was halt auch nicht nachweisbar ist, was ich letztendlich real damit geschafft habe, wäre das so, ich kriege irgendwann einen Fax von deren Anwälte und die sagen halt du, du, du, das darfst du nicht. Und dann sag ich, okay, ich mach's nicht mehr, dann zahl ich halt nur die Anwaltsgebühr von denen.
Genau.
Es können ganz schön hohe Anwaltsgebühren sein. Also je nachdem, was die Kanzlei berechnet, was die an Recherchegebühren und so voranschlagen. Manche Anwälte machen daraus ein ganz gutes Geschäft. Die machen daraus ein ganz gutes Geschäft. Da gibt es ein paar bekannte Namen in der Branche, die vielleicht...
Nicht desto viel verschwandt.
Die wir jetzt hier nicht nennen, die seit wahrscheinlich schon seit 15, 20 Jahren oder so mit Abmahnung ganz gut Geld verdienen.
Aber das ist nicht...
Nicht desto trotz ist es nicht Patent-Thematik.
Das Wort, das mit Ex-Anfängen und mit Plora aufhört. Zahlreich die Anrufer hier, wollen wir direkt mal weitermachen. Der Uwe ist dran aus Berlin-Mitte. Hallo Uwe.
Ja hallo, also erstmal zu eurer Rätsel. Also ich stell mir da zum Beispiel so was vor wie ein komprimiertes Bias. Ist das richtig?
Ja, das geht in die Richtung. Es handelt sich tatsächlich um einen Bootloader.
Es könnte natürlich auch... Ja, ich weiß nicht. Was ist jetzt, wenn ich zum Beispiel... Theoretisch weiß ich nicht. Ich hab auf meinem USB-Stick ein gezipptes Windows und entkomprimiere das und packe es sofort auf eine Platte. Was passiert dann? Hab ich da einen Patent verletzt oder wie ist das?
Nee, also das ist ja nur ein Teil, muss ich dazu sagen. Also das ist ein Teil einer Patentbeschreibung und ist jetzt keine Sache, die insgesamt als solche patentiert ist. Jedenfalls geht es darum, nicht in diesem Patent, wo es entnommen ist.
Das ist gar nicht patentiert, das ist eigentlich nur die Beschreibung.
Also das ist ein Beispiel dafür, wie komplex und wie schwierig zu lesen, vor allem für Leute, die sich jetzt nicht in die Materie eingearbeitet haben, diese Patentanmeldungen sind, mit was sie mich da rumschlagen muss und welche Möglichkeiten ich habe, als juristischer Laie im Prinzip so etwas nachzurecherchern. Also ob ich jetzt selber mit einem Projekt irgendwas verletze, und das ist ja das Problem dabei, dass einfach diese wahnsinnige Zahl von Patentanmeldungen, die ich eigentlich mitverfolgen müsste oder recherchieren müsste, wenn ich da irgendwie nachschaue, dass ich da als Privatperson überhaupt keine Chance habe eigentlich.
Ja und jetzt, das bringt mich auf den Gedanken, also beim Patentamt müssen diese ganzen technischen Begriffe dann immer auf Deutsch vorliegen, ist das richtig? Also man kann da nicht einfach RAM schreiben, sondern muss ROM, sondern muss nicht flüchtiger Speicher schreiben.
Also RAM und ROM, das verstehen die deutschen Patentprüfer schon. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass eine deutsche Patentanmeldung immer noch auf Deutsch geschrieben sein muss.
Heißt, wenn ich so ein Germanenfreak bin, der die deutsche Sprache absolut retten will, dann brauch ich mir eigentlich nur solche Patentanmeldungen, dann find ich für jedes Wort im technischen Bereich eigentlich eine deutsche Entsprechung.
Die Frage ist noch nicht entschieden, ob wir nicht die Sprache doch vielleicht viel mehr verderben in dem Augenblick.
Joachim, was ist das schärfste Wort, das du jemals erfunden hast?
Weiß ich zum Glück nicht mehr. Aber es gibt schon wirklich ziemlich verbogene Begriffe, die wir finden, eben um irgendeinen konkreten Begriff etwas zu abstrahieren. Dann ist das, ich weiß nicht, was die...
Ich hab mal von einem Verteilsenderamen gehört. Das ist ein Multicast-Frame.
Gut, das ist eine Übersetzungsfrage. Das passiert auch immer wieder. Aber manchmal schaffen wir auch ganz neue Begriffe. Ich weiß nicht, was zum Beispiel das Mikrofon-Aufhängengummi oder sowas, was ich hier gerade vor meiner Nase habe.
Das hört sich ja noch relativ zivil an. Das ist ja ganz normal.
Man landet ganz schnell bei der Donau-Dampfschifffahrt Kapitänsmitze oder so.
Ja gut, also, und der zweite war, eigentlich jetzt mal zu den Patenten näher einzugehen. Und zwar, vielleicht habt ihr die Sendung nicht von Anfang gehört. Wie lange kann denn das so im Schnitt dauern, bis so ein Patent geprüft ist, als Beispiel? Also wenn die Unterlagen so im Wesentlichen vollständig sind.
Also, das kann ganz schnell gehen. Sowas passiert in Ausnahmefällen sogar in weniger als einem Jahr. Übliche Größenordnungen sind so zwei, drei Jahre. Es kann aber auch mal, wenn es ein richtig komplizierter Fall ist und man so richtig ganz hart an die Grenze geht und möglichst viel rausholen will, zehn Jahre dauern. Aber eine übliche Größenordnung ist irgendwo zwei bis drei Jahre.
Aha, und wenn es an die Öffentlichkeit kommt, habe ich dann aber im Nachhinein immer noch die Patentrechte sozusagen.
Richtig, da muss man ganz klar unterscheiden. Erstmal muss man natürlich angemeldet haben, bevor es an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist, beim Patentamt eingereicht haben. Und dann, anderthalb Jahre später, wird die eigene Patentanmeldung veröffentlicht. Aber dann ist es egal, wenn man selbst auch schon wieder zwischendurch was veröffentlicht hat.
Gut, und jetzt wollte ich nämlich auf Folgendes hinaus. Also erstmal gibt es ja das Problem, ich weiß nicht, Patente in verschiedenen Ländern. Ich kann mich doch erinnern an diesen Walkman Erfinder, der da ewig, glaube ich, gegen Sony prozessiert hat.
Ja, jetzt hat er ja was gekriegt.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, war er nicht schon tot geworden?
Ne, ne, ne, er lebt noch.
Ja gut, also ich glaube der Chef von Sony war gestorben.
Der war es, genau.
Dann hab ich die Rechtsabteilung auf einen Kompromiss eingelassen oder so. Irgendwie sowas war das. Darum wollte ich jetzt mal drauf hinaus. Also erstmal ist ja die Frage. Ich meine, dieses Patentrecht mit der Verwertung, das bezieht sich ja nun mal halt auf eine Gesellschaft, die auf Profiterzielung basiert, sagen wir mal so. Also für mich ist es von vornherein klar, dass der, der da mehr Kohle hat, mehr Kapital, irgendwie im Vorteil ist. Weil es kommt ja oft darauf an, was man macht und wobei man sich erwischen lässt. Ich sag jetzt mal so ein Beispiel. Ich kenn hier aus Berlin, ist schon länger her eigentlich fast vor der Wiedervereinigung. Da musste man ja, um eine Förderung zu bekommen für ein Gewerbe, staatlicherseits musste man ja immer einen Unternehmensplan oder einen Geschäftsplan vorlegen. Ein Geschäftskonzept. Ich kenn da zum Beispiel jemand, der das gemacht hat, der da ewig keine Antwort gekriegt hat oder immer wieder Verbesserungen angemahnt wurden, bis der Typ irre geworden ist und Anwaltskosten ohne Ende hat. Und letztendlich ist es bei ihm abgelehnt worden, ist aber irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später von jemand ganz anderem förderungswürdig erachtet worden. Der hat dann auch da ewig geklagt. Also er hat jetzt einen Herzfehler mittlerweile, oder was weiß ich. Weil da steckt halt ein Polizeibeamter und ein Beamter aus der zuständigen Verwaltung für die Förderung drin. Und die haben einfach sein Konzept geklaut und ihm haben sie es nicht genehmigt. Versteht ihr, worauf ich hinaus will? So wenn das Ding jetzt ein Jahr beim Patentamt liegt, also wer hat denn die größeren Chancen, einem Sachbearbeiter zum Beispiel da irgendwie mal ein paar Infos zu entlocken? Also wenn ich sehe, was so zwischen Großunternehmen an Spionage oder so abläuft, ich weiß nicht, wenn ich da wirklich eine brandbrechende Erfindung hätte, die vielleicht noch jemand anders den Gewinn schmälert, sagen wir mal die Glühbirne, die zehnmal so lange leuchtet, also ich weiß nicht mal, ob ich den Patent, also ich weiß nicht.
Also das Patentamt ist bisher immer ziemlich dicht gewesen, da gibt es keine schlechten Erfahrungen in dieser Hinsicht.
In Deutschland jetzt.
Ja, und auch beim europäischen Patentamt genauso. Das ist ein Tiger, da kann man sich glaube ich sehr gut drauf verlassen.
Na gut, aber wie kam das denn zum Beispiel auf Sony, den Walkman, also den haben sie einfach parallel entwickelt, oder wie, oder nachentwickelt, oder wie kam das dazu?
Die haben den eigentlich sogar ganz und gar entwickelt. Ich meine, da hat einer in Aachen mal die gute Idee gehabt, dass man solch ein kleines Gerät entwickeln könnte und sich hatten sich schützen lassen.
Ich hab auch schon mal ein Foto davon gesehen, glaube ich.
Ja, ja genau, genau, aber er hat es also richtig entwickelt. In allen technischen Details hat es dann schon Sony, aber der andere hatte die Idee zuerst.
Aber die wussten nichts davon, letztendlich, meinst du im Ernst? Das wird ja auch nichts denn.
Nee, das ist genau.
Ja, und dann kommt es drauf an, japanisches Patentamt, deutsches Patentamt und dann zählt wer früher da war, oder wie?
Ganz genau.
Und wie kann man ihn überhaupt verklagen? Also ich meine, zum Beispiel, ich könnte als ein milliardenschweres Unternehmen, ich könnte ja sogar letztendlich irgendwie irgendwas manipulieren, um dieses Patent halt mit dem Datumstempeln ja früher entwickelt zu haben.
Nee, das geht eben nicht. Das kann man da so viel Einfluss hat man denn auf die Patentämter doch nicht, selbst wenn man großes Unternehmen ist. Und es ist ja auch so gewesen, dass dieser Aachner seinerzeit von Sony Geld haben wollte, weil er sagte, er hätte das Patent. Und dann hat Sony unglaublichen Aufwand getrieben, um das Patent möglichst vernichtigend herzubekommen. Und jetzt Postum, wenn man so will, haben sie ihm dann doch jede Menge Ehre zuteilwerden zu lassen.
Also hat Sony eigentlich einen dicken Fehler gemacht, indem sie nicht recherchiert haben, ja?
Ja, kann man sagen.
Und international zählt dann immer die frühere Anmeldung sozusagen?
Genau, der erste weltweit, erste Mal zuerst.
Na gut, aber jetzt sagst du trotzdem, das Patentamt ist dich. Aber sag mal, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Solange ich bestimmte technische Informationen vor der Öffentlichkeit verbergen kann, und ich als kleinen Tüftler nicht die Chance hab, die zu verklagen. Also Microsoft ist ja zum Beispiel, ich mein es ist jetzt ein bisschen ein anderer Fall, aber er ist doch zum Beispiel bekannt dafür, dass wir gegebene Standards übernehmen, leicht verändern und dann irgendwie halt Microsoft draufschlagen. Deswegen werden sie zwar nicht verklagt, aber man hat ja immerhin den Ärger, dass die damit Geld machen und die Scheiße funktioniert nicht mal, wie es im Standard steht.
Trotzdem kaufen sie alle, das ist das große Geheimnis daran.
Ja gut, aber da kann ich mich eigentlich auch gar nicht gegen wehren, selbst wenn ich es entwickelt habe.
Also es gibt schon zum Beispiel ein bekanntes, wichtiges Beispiel, wo eine sehr sehr kleine Firma eine Menge Geld aus so einem Branchenriesen rausgeprügelt hat. Das war Polaroid, das kennen wir heute alles als großes Unternehmen, das sich nun mittlerweile sehr erfolgreich wieder selbst zugrunde gerichtet hat. Aber die haben tatsächlich also die Sofortbildkamera damals erfunden. Und ich glaube Nikon oder Kodak oder irgendein Unternehmen war das. Die haben das also in riesigen Stück Zahlen auf den Markt geworfen, wurden dann von Polaroid verklagt. Und es wurde tatsächlich die Rekordsumme von einer Milliarde Dollar Schadensersatz an Polaroid gezahlt. Woraufhin die dann mit diesem Geld sich eben zu diesen doch recht großen Unternehmen gemausert haben, das sie dann jahrzehntelang doch dargestellt haben.
Aha.
Ja, aber zugestoßen, es gab mal so einen schönen Artikel, da ging es wirklich um diese Glühbeeren. Und dass die eigentlich auf Verschleiß gebaut sind, ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht schreibe ich noch was ins Board, weil da ging es darum, dass diese beiden Leute, die diese Glühbeeren auf den Markt schmeißen wollten, einfach mysteriöserweise ums Leben gekommen sein sollen. Oder ist das jetzt ein Hoax?
Könnte gut einer sein. Die Glühbeeren-Killer-Geschichte. Aber ich glaube, heutzutage ist alles auf Verschleiß gebaut.
Ist ja nix mehr so wie früher, aber er hält ja nichts mehr.
Na gut, also ihr haltet einen deutschen Beamten prinzipiell für nicht bestechlich.
Anderes Thema, ist ein anderer Blue Moon. Sagen wir es mal so. Das wären andere drei Stunden, die wir da füllen müssen.
Ja gut, aber diese Asymmetrie, die ist dann halt durch die Fehlerhaftigkeit des menschlichen Charakters irgendwo dann doch immer auf der Seite, wo einer mehr Geld hinten dran hat. Das würde ich einfach schon mal so gerne.
Das ist aber kein spezifisches Problem des Patentwesens. Das hast du überall, das Problem.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich alles patentiere, dann kann ich wirklich morgens, bevor ich aufstehe, schon mal loslaufen und gucken, ob ich einen Patent verletze, wenn ich die Tür aufmache.
Hey Uwe, man kann da paranoid werden. Deswegen muss man diesen Blue Moon heute Abend, dieses Chaosradio, auch mit Vorsicht genießen, weil man guckt da natürlich auf alles ganz, ganz skeptisch. Wie gesagt, man kann sich in den USA, wo dir auch ein gewisser Stil zu laufen, patentiert, insofern vorsichtig sein. Aber nur gewerblich. Ja, nur gewerblich natürlich. Uwe, danke dir erstmal für den Anruf, weil es sind noch ganz viele in der Leitung, die auch alle dran kommen wollen. So, der Jens ist am Telefon aus Oranienburg. Hallo Jens. Ja super, kein Ding.
Und zwar, ich hab da so eine Idee für ein Gesellschaftsspiel. Wollt das jetzt irgendwie patentieren lassen? Bin aber jetzt ein bisschen blauäugig und wollte jetzt mal fragen, wie das denn so läuft.
Puh, ist kein Patent wahrscheinlich.
Ist irgendwie gebraucht. Patent geht nicht. Also für die Spielidee gibt's keinen Patentschutz.
Achso, das wäre schon mal super eigentlich, oder?
Ja, super oder nicht. Je nachdem, wenn man der Schöpfer ist, wenn man die Spielidee hatte, dachte man, ich hätte ja doch gerne geschützt vielleicht. Was man eventuell schützen kann, ist zum Beispiel die ganze Ausgestaltung und wie das Ganze aussieht. Das könnte urheberrecht schutzfähig sein. Und, also nicht die Spielidee, aber wie das Ganze eben ausgestaltet ist. Und es kann natürlich sogar sein, dass man, wenn man da irgendwelche Männchen braucht, die sich irgendwie geschickt bewegen oder so, dann könnte da sogar eine technische Erfindung drin stecken. Aber die Spielidee ist nicht schutzfähig. Das war ein Scherz, aber das ist aber diese berühmte Technik.
Die Technizität, die da nicht gegeben ist, der Technikbezug, liegt das da dran, bei der Spielidee?
Ganz genau. Weil die Spielidee eben nicht technisch ist, kann sie nicht patentiert werden. Deswegen gibt es keinen Patentschutz dafür. Und weil die Spielidee auch erstmal noch kein Werk darstellt, noch nicht verkörperlicht ist, gibt es deswegen auch erstmal für die Spielidee als solche auch keinen Urheberrechtsschutz.
Na gut, ich hätte jetzt schon eine Spielplatte, habe jetzt schon Karten und so kleine Männchen, die man bewegen kann. Aber das Konzept an sich ist halt die Idee.
Ja genau, das Konzept, das geht ihm leider nicht, aber alles drumherum. Zum Beispiel die kleinen Männchen, die man bewegen kann und so, die könnten dann doch auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise schutzfähig sein.
Und du kannst dir einen guten Namen einfallen lassen für das Spiel. Und wenn der Name sozusagen zieht, dann kannst du unabhängig vom Patentschutz dann ganz gut Geld verdienen damit.
Mit dem Namen. Genau, mit dem Name.
Und die Spielbrettgestaltung könnte zum Beispiel durch ein Geschmacksmuster schützbar sein.
Also müsste ich mir jetzt praktisch irgendeine Firma suchen, da das vorstellen und fragen, ob sie daran Interesse hätten.
Oder selber vertreiben.
Mit den Firmen, wie gesagt, dann würde ich erstmal vorsichtig sein. Ob das nachher so zu deinen Gunsten ausgeht oder ob dann nachher du einen Prozess gegen eine Firma führen musst, die das Spiel unter ihrem Namen auf den Markt bringt, was schon vorgekommen.
Oder geschickt sein. Die Schwierigkeit ist, dass solche Sachen wie die Gestaltung der Karten leicht von der Firma übernommen werden kann. Da kann man nichts gegen machen, es sei denn, man kann nachweisen, dass man der Urheber war. Da gibt es zum Beispiel solche Tricks, dass man die Karten einfach in einen Umschlag an sich selbst schickt und den Umschlag erstmal nicht öffnet, damit er geschlossen ist, damit man nachweisen kann, zu dem Zeitpunkt, und zwar bevor ich bei euch war, hatte ich diese Gestaltung schon und deswegen bin ich der Urheber.
Also, ich soll jetzt einfach weiter daran arbeiten und Januschen irgendwie patentieren lassen, weil da nicht geht.
Patentieren ist nicht, genau. Es sei denn, die Figürchen bewegen sich auf ganz geschickte Art und Weise, sowie noch keine zuvor.
Die könnten ganz plump sein.
Plumpe Figürchen. So, und der Joshua ist am Telefon aus Tempelhof Berlin.
Ich wollte eben noch was dazu sagen. Jetzt wird die ganze Zeit darüber gesprochen, wofür die Patente gut sind und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich wollte eben noch was erwähnen, weil ich selber in der Uni eine Erfolgsung gehabt hab. Was ich sehr interessant fand, und zwar, wie das überhaupt läuft, wenn man jetzt die Idee hat. Oder wenn man jetzt eine Idee hat, wie man das sich patentieren lässt und wie man seine Idee möglichst schnell schützen kann und so weiter und so fort. Und zwar gibt es, hab ich gehört, beim Europäischen Patentamt sogar die Möglichkeit, so ein kurz umrissenes, muss jetzt noch keine Ausfertigung vom Patent sein, aber eben die Idee, ausgefertigt, vielleicht auch mit einer Skizze und so weiter und so fort, alles zusammenzustellen und sogar per Fax da hinzuschicken zum Europäischen Patentamt. Und in dem Moment ist es halt sogar schon geschützt, weil die es wohl mit Zeitstempel und Tagestempel und Zeitstempel da aufnehmen. Und dann ist man erstmal auf der sicheren Seite, dass einem nicht irgendjemand anders kommen kann und einem die Idee im letzten Moment klauen kann.
Das ist richtig, auf diese Weise hat man den sogenannten Anmeldetag, also das Prioritätsrecht oder so erworben, das heißt den Tag erworben, an dem man sozusagen einem nichts mehr entgegenhalten werden kann, aber nur für das, was da schon drinsteht, das heißt, wenn man da zu wenig reinschreibt und sich später auf irgendein Detail kaprizieren will oder zurückziehen will, was da noch nicht drinsteht, dann geht das nicht.
Ja, ich sag das nur deswegen, weil ich kenn selbst jemand, der hatte schon einige gute Ideen und meint irgendwie, immer wenn er die weitererzählt, im Vertrauen müssen wohl 1000 Abwehrgeräte in der Gegend gewesen sein, zufällig.
Dann war die vielleicht nicht so einzigartig.
Vielleicht hat er dann doch schon gesehen, mag sein, dass es schon ein Zufall war und dass es schon früher vielleicht da war und er es nur nicht recherchiert hat vernünftig. Aber nicht, dass man sich, oder dass irgendjemand eine wirklich gute Idee hat jetzt, wo er denkt, wow, jetzt bin ich aber richtig auf eine coole Idee gekommen, die ist so genial, die gibt es bestimmt noch nicht, dass er sich nachher nicht ärgert, wenn er da nicht das Genuss hat und das Geld für einen Fax ausgegeben hat. Bis dahin kostet das ja auch noch nichts, also noch kein Patent, aber auf jeden Fall ist es schon damit geschützt.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis übrigens. Also wenn man nur eine gute Beschreibung seiner technischen Erfindungen hat, die einreicht beim Patentamt, ohne Gebühr zu zahlen und sagt, wer man selbst ist und sagt, man will ein Patent dafür, dann hat man genau dieses Prioritätsrecht schon erworben und es kostet einen außer der Gebühr für das Fax keinen Pfennig.
Genau. Und außerdem noch auf die Recherchemöglichkeit, die man beim europäischen Patentamt hat. Also es gibt auch Anbieter, die Kosten in Geld, so kann man mit Kreditkarte über Internet auch bezahlen. Aber es gibt auch die Möglichkeit zur freien Recherche, dass man erst mal gucken kann, wenn man eine Idee hat, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt, da in die Richtung weiterzuentwickeln oder ob schon längst jemand drauf gekommen ist und das halt noch nicht im Handel verfügbar ist oder ebenfalls noch nicht wirklich öffentlich ist oder man es halt nur noch nicht kennt, nicht dass man da irgendwie Entwicklungsarbeit in eine Idee investiert oder verschwendet dann halt, obwohl es es schon längst gibt.
Wobei jetzt das Webinterface zum Beispiel vom Patenten bis jetzt nicht wirklich benutzerfreundlich oder es macht nicht gerade Spaß, da drin rumzuklicken, sag ich mal. Also vielleicht hat ja von euch noch jemand einen Tipp parat, wie man da irgendwie sinnvoll vorgehen kann. Ich finde das eher unübersichtlich. Also ich meine, die erste Anlaufadresse sollte immer erstmal Google sein. Da habe ich schon oft einen relevanten Stand der Technik gefunden. Ansonsten gibt es halt auf die Internetseiten vom Deutschen Patent- und Markenamt, also das www.dpma.de und bei dem Europäischen Patentamt einige Links-Suchmaschinen und man kann tatsächlich schon mit Schlüsselwörtern doch einiges finden.
Aber es gibt eben das Problem, das haben wir ja vorhin schon ein bisschen gehört, dass das sehr prosaarische Anmeldungen sind. Und wenn man also nicht genau weiß, mit welcher prosaarer Patentanmelder das Ganze verpackt hat, dann ist es unheimlich schwierig, die richtigen Schlüsselwörter für die Suche zum Beispiel zu finden. Und wir haben ja die vorhinige Statistik gehört, hier 350.000 Patente. Okay, nicht alle werden zutreffen, aber man muss ja rausfinden, ob dann nun schon was zutrifft. Und wenn man nichts gefunden hat und sich sagt, na okay, dann gehe ich jetzt hier in die Vollen, investiere und mache und erfinde hier vor mich hin, dann ist man auch nicht auf der sicheren Seite. Es kann sein, man hat nur das falsche Schlüsselwort eingegeben bei der Suche.
Naja, ich denke mal, bevor man jetzt wirklich in die Vollen geht und wirklich viel Geld investiert, dann lohnt es sich natürlich schon nochmal jemanden professionell zu beauftragen, der sich da informiert. Aber erst mal vorab, wenn man die Idee überhaupt hat, zu sehen, ob das eigentlich Schwachsinn ist und schon längst erfunden ist, oder ob man das, also einfach um das einzuschätzen, ob es sich überhaupt vielleicht lohnt. Zeit, das zu entwickeln, denke ich mal, reicht das, was angeboten wird, doch durchaus aus, um sich wenigstens einen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Ist auch so. Ich meine, die letzte Sicherheit kriegt man nie. Selbst wenn man sich die ganzen Profis heranzieht, die es auf dieser Erde so gibt, selbst die können ja nicht die letzte Sicherheit verschaffen. Und einen ganz schönen guten Überblick kann man genau mit diesen öffentlichen Recherchemöglichkeiten bekommen.
Und wenn man einen Treffer hat, dann weiß man auf jeden Fall, man kann sich die Arbeit sparen.
Joshua, zufrieden?
Sonst hätte ich nicht weiter zu sagen.
Alles klar, danke dir für den Anruf.
Danke, tschau.
So, der Frank aus Berlin-Charlottenburg. Hallo Frank.
oder der Patentklauer überhaupt, denke ich mal, ist so, wie er geht. Und mit seinem Microsoft und überhaupt irgendwie. Also der Mann hat ja noch nie irgendwie was selber erfunden, sondern hat entweder irgendwie immer was gekauft. Oder hat die Firma hinterher so platt gemacht, dass dann nur noch weine Sachen da verkauft wurden. Und ich denke mal, was steckt denn von Bill Gates in irgendeinem Programm von Microsoft drin?
Nichts.
Sagt man immer.
Naja, aber entweder hat er bei Apple geklaut. Oder, wie weiß ich, also ich denke mal, der wird auch irgendwann bei Anfang Berlin uns richtig abkuppern.
Ich würde mal sagen, man muss ein bisschen mit der Wortwahrheit ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Also hier wird immer viel von klauen und abkuppern und so.
Das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung.
Ja klar, aber so reden ja viele Leute und so. Und ich meine, der Sinn und Zweck des Patentwesens zum Beispiel ist ja auch durch die Offenlegung, dieses Kopieren irgendwann zu ermöglichen überhaupt. Das heißt, da steckt immer schon die Idee drin, dass sich gute Ideen, gute Technologien verbreiten sollen. Dazu muss man kopieren. Und deswegen muss man immer, also das klauen, man klaut ein Apfel. Da ist der Apfel weg und so.
Ja okay, aber vielleicht hat er, ich sag mal so, vielleicht hat er die Idee abkuppert.
Ja, hat sich inspirieren lassen, sagen wir mal.
Aber ohne Patente muss man ja auch sagen, dass Ideen klauen erlaubt. Das ist eigentlich der Grundsatz.
Naja, aber dann frag ich mich, warum seine Firma in Amerika vor Erich gestellt wurde und hier in Europa wahrscheinlich auch vor Erich kommt.
Da geht es um wettbewerbsrechtliche Dinge, also nicht um irgendwelche patentrechtliche Problematik. Aber durchaus ist Microsoft auch schon zu Schaden, dass Erzahlungen aufgrund von Patenten gezwungen wurden. Im Fall in Frankreich habe ich noch irgendwo dunkel im Kopf. Aber ich weiß nicht, worauf du ansprichst mit der Europäischen Union, das ist ein wettbewerbsrechtliches Verfahren, hat mit Patenten nichts zu tun.
Naja, aber ich weiß nicht. Ich benutze auch selber dieses Windows. Aber wenn ich mir diese ganze Geschichte, ich bin ja nun schon ein paar Jahre Computerfreak irgendwo, wenn ich das so nachvollziehe, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke mal, von dem ist nichts eigener. Angefangen von dem DOS, was da mal irgendjemand abgekauft hat und dann zu IBM. Ich meine, das ist nicht verwerslich.
Das ist ein cleverer Geschäftsmann halt.
Kapitalismus ist total so, dass man, wenn man Kohle hat, irgendwas kaufen kann. Aber er hat ja genug angefilmt, einfach Ausgebote plattgemacht und irgendwo... Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, vielleicht ist das jetzt nicht so richtig rechtlich, wie ich das jetzt rüberbringe und in eurem Pass auch vielleicht nicht so in die Sendung. Aber von der Sache hier im weitesten Sinne ist es doch eigentlich so.
Das zeigt eigentlich nur, dass die Welt auch ohne Patente schlecht sein kann, wenn man so will.
Na gut, das würde ich eigentlich nun mal loswerden kurz.
Wenn man an der Stelle vielleicht noch aufgreifen will, war das mit dem Patente und die Idee, dass man dann Dinge offenlegt und dass man später vielleicht mal auch Entwicklungen darauf aufbauen kann, ist eines der wesentlichen Probleme irgendwie, finde ich im Computerzeitalter und im Internetzeitalter, die Dauer von 20 Jahren. Dass also hier einen Anspruch über 20 Jahre gegeben wird oder maximal 20 Jahre, wenn es auch immer schön verlängert wird, welche Technologien von vor 20 Jahren sind denn noch relevant im Computer? Ja, sicher gibt es natürlich immer wieder genug. Aber selbst von eBay, also Amazon war es mit dem One-Trick-Patent, ist es ja auch in Verruf geraten mit den Patenten. Und da gibt es also ein Interview mit dem Amazon CEO, wo er eben sagte, er würde im Internetzeitalter 3-5 Jahre als maximale Patentspanne für durchaus ausreichend halten danach. Wäre also sinnvoll, das frei zu geben.
Gut, lassen wir mal so stehen und sickern in den Köpfen, weil wir machen jetzt gleich erstmal Nachrichten. Einen kurzen Tipp geben wir noch, bevor wir in die letzte halbe Stunde gehen. Und zwar feiert der Chaos Computer Club, der hier auch diese Sendung des Chaos Radio betreibt, seinen 23. Geburtstag. Der wird gefeiert am 11. September dieses Jahres. Ja, Infos findet ihr unter www.ccc.de slash 23. Gefeiert wird in Berlin in der Sea-Base.
Wenn Fritz in der Friednis, dann 103, 1.
23 Uhr, nee, 20 Uhr, 30. Genau, wo ich das Wetter hingelegt? Also heute Nacht bleibt der immer gleich, ist immer das gleiche. Heute Nacht gibt es wenig Wolken und keine Regen. Die Temperaturen fallen auf 9 bis 4 Grad. Örtlich gibt es Nebel. Am Tag wird es sonnig bei Werten zwischen 20 und 24 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Ketter-Heinrich.
In New York ist der Welt-Sicherheitsrat zu einer Dringlichkeitssitzung über das Geiseldrama in einer Schule im Kaukasus zusammengekommen. Diplomaten erwarten, dass die UNO die jüngste Serie von Terrorakten in Russland verurteilen wird. Terroristen haben gestern Morgen eine Schule in der russischen Teilrepublik Nord-Ossetien gestürmt und 300 Menschen in ihre Gewalt gebracht, darunter 130 Kinder. Die Geiselnämmer fordern den Abzug der russischen Truppen aus Tschetschenien. Die US Luftwaffe hat ein Wohngebiet in der irakischen Stadt Fallujah angegriffen. Nach Angaben der irakischen Polizei wurden dabei 9 Zivilisten getötet. Unter den Opfern sind 3 Kinder. Das Bundeskabinett hat Änderungen bei der Arbeitsmarktreform Hartz IV beschlossen. So soll das Arbeitslosengeld II bereits Anfang Januar 2005 ausgezahlt werden. Außerdem dürfen Kinder der Betroffenen jetzt bis zu 4.100 Euro besitzen. Katrin Göring-Eckhardt und Christa Sager bleiben die Vorsitzenden der Bundestagsfraktion der Grünen. Auf einer Klausur in Bad Saro wurden beide Frauen für weitere 2 Jahre im Amt bestätigt. In Venedig ist das 61. Filmfestival eröffnet worden. Zum Auftakt wird The Terminal von Steven Spielberg gezeigt. Der Film mit Tom Hanks in der Hauptrolle läuft außerhalb der Konkurrenz. Insgesamt bewerben sich in diesem Jahr 21 Filme um den goldenen Löwen. Der Verkehr auf Ritz. Keine aktuellen Meldungen mehr. Gute Fahrt für euch.
Präsentiert.
Und viele mehr. Kurz gesagt. Ritz präsentiert. Berner. Das Rennen. Ein herzerfrischendes Moin Moin an alle Durchgeknallten. Jede Menge Musik und dazu jede Menge Motoren. In allen Gründen, in voller Lautstärke und in rauen Mengen. Dieses Wochenende, live, live auf dem Euro Speedway Lausitz. Werner, das Rennen.
Mehr Infos, fritzt.de.
Letzte halbe Stunde ist eingeläutet, bis ein Uhr geht's noch. Chaosradio zum Thema Patente heute Abend. Philipp Börker ist da, angehender Patentanwalt zusammen mit Joachim von Oppen, Patentanwalt. Robert Gehring, Gast auch bei uns Informatiker in der TU Berlin. Frank Harald vom Chaosradio, vom CCC und meine Person, der Max. Schon viel geredet worden, aber es ist immer noch Fragen offen. Zum Beispiel der Tom hat eine gestellt unter 033 177 97 110 35 aus Cottbus. Hallo Tom. Was ist deine Frage?
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die ganze Geschichte in die Patentsache mit reinfliegt oder ob es sich um eine Lizenzgeschichte handelt. Also das ist ja weißes Ohne miteinander verbunden teilweise, ne? Also es geht speziell, ich entwickle selber im Windows mit Microsoft Software Programme, Anwendungsprogramme und meine Frage ist jetzt, sind die Steuerelemente, die ich benutze und die, die ich dann weitergebe an den Kunden, sind die jetzt patentiert oder sind die nur lizenziert, indem ich die Entwicklungsoberfläche kaufe bzw. den Copyler und so weiter?
Das ist eine Lizenzfrage, ob du die weitergeben kannst oder nicht?
Ja, das Weitergeben ja, aber ich baue zum Beispiel eine Microsoft Outlook-Bahn nach, hat da irgendjemand einen Patent drauf oder ist mir da jetzt nicht so sicher?
Nein, wenn du von einem Lieferanten Komponenten beziehst, die du mit einbaust und dann auch weitergibst, dann gibt dir dieser Lieferant ja irgendwelche Lizenzbedingungen vor und da steht dann drin, sie dürfen meinetwegen so und so oft das Ganze weitergeben oder je nachdem wie die ausgestaltet sind und wenn man sich daran hält, dann würde ich sagen, ist man in der Regel schon auf einer relativ sicheren Seite, was natürlich sein kann ist, dass das Zusammenspiel der Komponenten, was du dann selber ja entwickelst, dazu führt, dass du irgendwas herstellst, was seinerseits patentgeschützt ist und dann bräuchtest du eine Lizenz von demjenigen, der das Patent hält da dranne und das müsstest du aber wiederum selber recherchieren dann. Dann müsstest du von dem eine Lizenz bekommen und du müsstest seinerseits wiederum eine Lizenz schreiben für diejenigen, die dein Programm benutzen, wenn du die Lizenz von dem Patentinhaber bekommen hast.
Ich habe jetzt leider nicht von Anfang an zugehört, deshalb weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob jetzt Software, zum Beispiel schreibt ein E-Mail-Programm, das sieht so aus, die Outlook benutzt halt unter der Oberfläche nur andere Strukturen. Ist das jetzt patentiert oder ist das nicht, das Outlook an sich ist ja ein Patent, oder? Nee, nicht.
Also patentiert sind immer Verfahren und keine Programme. Also wenn überhaupt, dann gibt es einen Patentschutz für irgendwelche Abwicklungen von Protokollen oder so. Und ich bezweifle mal, dass bei E-Mail-Programmen da jetzt großartige Patente in Frage kommen würden, weil die Technologie ist schon ziemlich alt. Also da hat sich in den letzten paar Jahren nicht so viel entwickelt.
Ja, zum Beispiel könnte diese Idee, diese Buttons links haben diese Leiste oder so, das könnte vielleicht sein.
Genau, Details der Funktionalität von Outlook könnten patentiert sein.
Könnten, das muss ich recherchieren jetzt, ja?
Genau.
Oder zum Beispiel diese Buttons, wo ich dann noch so ein kleines Dreieck dran hab, wenn ich da rauf drücke und dann die Maus runterziehe, dass ich dann so eine Auswahlliste hab.
Das könnte ein Patent sein, ja?
Jaja, also grafische Oberflächen sind relativ stark inzwischen mit Patentschutz belegt und da würde ich mich an der Stelle auf die Recherche erstmal konzentrieren.
Es gibt zum Beispiel das berühmt berüchtigte Patent auf die Palette mit Reitern, also über so eine Reiterdarstellung von mehreren, also diese Registerkarten im Prinzip, eine Registerkartendarstellung ist patentiert zum Beispiel.
Aber die benutzt doch fast jedes Programm.
Ja, das ist ja eben die Idiotie, dass alles Mögliche patentiert ist, was man ständig überall verwendet oder als gegeben annimmt oder als allgemein gültig oder wie auch immer oder als trivial, offensichtlich.
Und bezahlen die alle Lizenzgebühren dafür?
Ja, das glaube ich eher nicht. Die warten einfach, also Unternehmen, was jetzt Lizenzgebühren einkassieren wollte, müsste ja irgendwo hingehen, wo was zu holen ist. Die müssen ihre Anwälte in Gang setzen und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall würden die, wenn sie halbwegs ökonomisch nachdenken, zu großen Verletzern gehen, von denen wirklich was zu holen ist, zu irgendeinem kleinen Patentverletzer zu gehen und zu sagen, hier zahle uns mal bitte 75 Euro oder so. Das ist ziemlich aufwendig, wenn man die vielen kleinen Entwickler anguckt und so. Das lohnt sich nicht so richtig. Also wenn man einen großen Verletzer findet, also jemanden, der es in einem großen Stil einsetzt, das lohnt sich eigentlich schon dahin zu gehen, aber bei kleinen Entwicklern eher nicht.
Das heißt, Entwickler sind Verbrecher.
Und ja, es ist ja kein Kriminalgeschichte, in dem Falle bei Patenten noch nicht. Urheberrecht sieht schon teilweise anders aus. Aber man begehrt sozusagen einen Rechtsverstoß.
Das mit dem Verbrecher kommt übrigens auch darauf an, wie schlecht du programmierst. Kann natürlich sein, dass du einfach scheiß Programme schreibst.
Aber das ist doch vielleicht noch eine. Entschuldigung. Die Patentverletzung kann tatsächlich mit fünf Jahren Strafe gelegt werden. Oh, insofern ist das nicht nur ein kleiner Rechtsverstoß in weniger Weise.
Ich habe dazu gleich noch eine andere Frage. Und zwar könnte jetzt eine größere Firma wie Microsoft oder IBM, die ja jetzt Irrational aufgekauft haben vor kurzem, könnte dir jetzt auf die Idee kommen, und zum Beispiel irgendwelche Designpattern patentieren lassen? Also da ist nicht so meine Befürchtung, weil die nutzt man jeden Tag.
Das ist ziemlich schwierig, das Designpattern zu schützen. Also weil man immer nur konkrete Bildschirme, wenn man so will, zum Beispiel per Geschmacksmuster oder Designpattern schützen kann. Aber nicht das ganze Patternkonzept, wenn man so will. Das ganze Konzept, das Farbkonzept oder wie auch immer was dahinter steht. Deswegen ist das gar nicht so leicht.
Also es muss für ein Patent immer sehr konkret sein. Es muss ja konkret beschrieben werden. Und so ein Designpattern ist glaube ich zu abstrakt, um das jetzt hinreichend konkret patentieren zu können.
Ist klar, also könnte sich Google deine Suchmaschine patentieren lassen?
Eine Suchmaschine als solche wiederum nicht, aber eine bestimmte Art und Weise der Verknüpfung von Computern zu Suchclustern und ich weiß nicht, was mit einer Datenbank hinten dran und ein bestimmter Typ von Index und usw. Das wahrscheinlich schon.
Vielleicht eine bestimmte Art Präsentation der Ergebnisse.
Also zum Beispiel hier Apple. Apple macht ja Mac OS 10 Betriebssystem und die haben sich ja was patentieren lassen, was sie zum Beispiel noch gar nicht benutzen. Da gab es immer diese große Diskussion, machen die das jetzt, machen die das nicht, sogenannte Häufchen zu bilden. Also du kannst Dokumente auf dem Desktop stapeln, sogenannte Piles bilden. Und da gibt es ein Patent für, dass man auf dem Desktop Dokumente virtuell stapeln kann. Das haben die sich zum Beispiel patentieren lassen.
Wo ich dann aber wieder ernsthaft irgendwo die Frage aufwerfen muss, ist das so eine tolle neue Erfindung? Ich meine, ich kann auf meinem physischen Arbeitsplatz auch Blätter stapeln. Warum soll ich sie nicht auf meinem virtuellen Arbeitsplatz auch stapeln können?
Weil das total unpraktisch ist.
Um genau zu wissen, was die eigentlich geschützt bekommen haben, muss man eigentlich in das Patent gucken. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch immer diese Geschichte von dem Amazon One-Click-Patent in Wirklichkeit. Wenn man sich genau anschaut, schützt das was ganz anderes, als alle annehmen. Das weiß man.
Ja, wenn man das genau liest und man muss immer das lesen, was wirklich in den Patentansprüchen drin steht, dann wurde da tatsächlich nur ein Patent auf eine Geschenkmethode verteilt, wo ein Benutzer, also einem Bekannten oder sonst wem, ein Geschenk schenken kann per One-Click. Und dieses Verfahren ist so exakt spezifiziert, dass ein unabdingbarer Schritt dieses Verfahrens ist, dass dem Empfänger des Geschenks eine E-Mail zugestellt wird, in der ihm mitgeteilt wird, da will dir einer was schenken, jetzt schick uns mal deine Postadresse zurück, dann kriegst du dein Geschenk. So und jetzt muss mir mal irgendjemand sagen, was ist das Skandalöse an diesem Patent? Okay, ich meine es existiert, mich würde es niemals stören, wenn ich einen Webshop aufmachen würde, weil jeder, der so irgendwas verschenken will über Internet, der wird doch im Grunde erst mal selber die Postadresse des Beschenkten angeben und wer das nicht will, der wird also durch das Amazon-Patent davon abgehalten und ich muss sagen, kann mir nicht vorstellen, wer das eigentlich wirklich machen wollen würde.
Also ich halte das nicht für so unrealistisch. Also ich meine, gerade im Internet gibt es viele Bekanntschaften, wo ich nicht unbedingt die Postanschrift des Gegenübers kenne, sondern der hat halt nur irgendeinen Nickname, dem will ich jetzt was schränken und dann wird eben diese Maschinerie in Gang gesetzt und das geht halt einfach nicht. Also ich finde es äußerst trivial, was da gemacht wird.
Die haben zum Beispiel die Zubischtnist.
Ich kenne die Adresse nicht, also frage ich den Empfänger nach der Adresse und das ist jetzt eine tolle Erfindung.
Ich meine, einfach Adressen von irgendwerem anzugeben. Wenn man ihn vorher gefragt hat, per E-Mail, willst du deine Adresse angeben, dann ist das glaube ich eher kein Datenschutzproblem.
Das kann man ja auch weiterhin tun, nur in diesem Fall schickt ja Amazon also die E-Mail raus und wie gesagt, die Umgehungsmöglichkeiten sind so vielfältig, dass ich da eigentlich kein Problem sehe.
Ja, aber abgesehen von der Umgehung ist es schon fragwürdig, ob denn ein Patentwesen, was sich darauf konzentriert, Geschenkmethoden mit E-Mail zu schützen. Man muss ja immer noch sagen, das ist ein Exklusivrecht. Das heißt, da steckt ein Verbotsrecht dahinter.
Aber da kannst du auch bei den Eiswürfen genauso argumentieren.
Hätte man auch machen können, ja klar. Also, ist schon die Frage. Eigentlich würde man sagen, also jedenfalls als Techniker, der ich ja irgendwo bin, würde ich sagen, wenn etwas ganz Außerordentliches erfunden worden ist und da ist auch sehr viel Aufwand betrieben worden dafür und so, dann kann man darüber nachdenken, dafür so einen gewissen exklusiven Schutz zu geben. Aber wenn denn nun so Alltags Erfindungen, die einem so gerade kommen, man hat gerade seinen Eiswürfelfach aufgemacht und da sieht man, oh, da sind ja die Eiswürfel hier, die haben ein Loch drinnen und jetzt gieße ich einfach ein bisschen Eierlikör drüber und da habe ich einen Cocktail und dann gehe ich zum Patentanwalt oder zum Patentanwalt und lasse das patentieren. Wenn wir so weit kommen, dass also jeder auf nahezu alles so erstmal auf die Idee kommt, oh, ganz tolle, exklusive Idee und ich brauche jetzt hier den Staat im Hintergrund, um das zu schützen, dann ist schon irgendwie denke ich, das sinnvolle Maß irgendwie überschritten worden und man muss sich vielleicht ein bisschen darauf konzentrieren, was verdient denn eigentlich diesen gesellschaftlichen Schutz über?
Ja, ich meine, das beantwortet sich davon selbst. Wenn dieses Patent überhaupt irgendjemand stört auf die Eiswürfel, dann gibt es offenbar ein Interesse an dem Schutz dieser Sache, denn wenn jetzt plötzlich 100.000 Hersteller Eiswürfel mit Cocktail drin produzieren und verkaufen wollen, dann war das offenbar eine verdammt interessante Idee und wenn das langweilig und trivial war, dann wird sich da eben keiner drum scheren.
Das Problem ist einfach, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, die Sachen erfindet wie Eiswürfel, in denen sich schon der Cocktail befindet.
Ich meine, das ist noch nicht das Problem, da leben wir nun mal drinnen. Aber die Frage ist, wenn es dann wirklich so ist, dass alles, was irgendwie neu und so ist, einen Schutz verdient, warum schützen wir dann nicht jede noch so beliebige Geschäftsidee? Da gibt es aber dann wiederum Argumente, dass gesagt wird, nein, nein, nur was Technisches usw. usf. Also wir sind uns in gewisser Weise in der Gesellschaft irgendwie schon einig, dass nicht alles grundsätzlich einen Monopole-Schutz verdient, wie es ja im Patent- und Urheberrecht in gewisser Weise erteilt wird. Nur, wo zieht man die Grenzen? Und heutzutage sieht es schon stark danach aus, dass die Grenzen immer weiter und immer weiter ausfallen. Und so war es eigentlich, glaube ich, nicht ursprünglich gedacht.
Da ist ein bisschen was dran. Ich meine, die Diskussion Geschäftsideen zum Beispiel über Patente schützen zu lassen, die ist jetzt in Gang gekommen, weil das Ganze in den Loops A geht. Hier geht es noch nicht. Jetzt stellen wir uns plötzlich die Frage, warum eigentlich nicht? Und diese Frage ist jedes Mal eine Grächin-Frage, muss neu beantwortet werden. Und da kommen die ganzen Grundsatzfragen natürlich ins Spiel. Wem nutzen Patente? Sind sie vom gesamtgesellschaftlichen Nutzen oder nicht? Das spielt natürlich auch eine Rolle. Wie die Antwort hinterher aussehen wird, das weiß ich auch nicht. Aber ich meine, es ist auch schon mal gut und wichtig, dass diese Fragen gestellt werden. Und wir sind uns, glaube ich, einig, dass es bestimmte Dinge gibt, die es wirklich verdienen, geschützt zu werden. Und wo man da die Grenze zieht, ist natürlich schwierig. Und dass jetzt die Praxis den Weg gegangen ist, zu sagen, okay, wir ziehen die Grenze so, dass zum Beispiel eben das Patent am Nachweisen muss, das etwas nahegelegen hat, was dazu führt, dass es auch relativ triviale Patente gibt, worüber keiner wirklich glücklich ist, glaube ich. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die sich möglicherweise aber auch in absehbarer Zeit wieder umkehrt.
Wir haben nur noch zehn Minuten Zeit. Ich würde einfach mal sagen, Tom, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ich hoffe, du hast jetzt nicht nur die ganze Zeit am Telefon zugehört. Zuhören ist ja grundsätzlich auch toll. Tom, danke dir für den Anruf, weil der Peter ist noch dran. Peter aus Kreuzberg noch als letzter. Hallo, Peter.
Hallo.
Abend.
Jo, ich wollte eigentlich auch was sagen zum Thema Trivialpatente. Das Stichwort ist jetzt schon gefallen bei euch auch. Und zwar ist es ein bisschen anders, als ich das eigentlich so wahrgenommen habe, die Geschichte mit Trivialpatenten. Und zwar habt ihr also auch schon das Patent genannt, mit dem ich das jetzt auch am ehesten mit in den Zusammenhang bringe, das ist dieses sogenannte Karteireiterpatent.
Hast du die letzten 10 Minuten, 15 Minuten zugehört oder hast du uns? Genau. Genau, darüber haben wir auch gesprochen zum Teil schon. Genau.
Deswegen finde ich es auch ganz spannend. Und zwar habe ich da ein bisschen andere Sicht, auch als ihr, die da jetzt so gesprochen habt, beziehungsweise noch andere Aspekte. Nämlich gerade dieses Karteireiterpatent zum Beispiel, sag ich jetzt mal, also trivial wird ja häufig so gesagt, naja, ist ja eigentlich ganz simpel, ganz primitiv, sowas gehört doch nicht patentiert. Da sag ich eigentlich, je einfacher, umso genialer. Also ich sag mal jetzt, trivial heißt nicht einfach, sondern ja jetzt im Sinne von naheliegend, das heißt, naja, war eigentlich keine Erfindung.
Aber nun ist es ja so, dass diese Karteireiter Nummer, ich meine Karteireiter gab's schon bevor es Software gab. Da gab's Karteireiter.
Genau. Das heißt, das ist der eine Punkt, dass es sowas schon mal in der Realwelt sozusagen gab. Das heißt also eigentlich, es geht um den Schritt, das Ganze in Software umzusetzen. Da kann man jetzt fragen, ist es deswegen jetzt nicht trivial, weil es Software ist, was ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde, ja, das ist nicht trivial, weil Programmieren ist eine ganz andere Welt. Sowas hinzukriegen, dass es auf dem Computer funktioniert, ist einfach nicht trivial.
Aber das ist nicht das, was patentiert wird?
Genau.
Also es wird nicht der arbeitsaufwand oder wie kompliziert es ist, das umzusetzen. Darüber bezieht sich kein Patent an.
Aber das ist schon die Kernfrage, um die es geht. Ob die Übertragung solch eines aus der realen Welt bekannten Konzepts auf den Bildschirmen nahegelegen hat oder nicht. Wenn jemand auf die Idee kommt, ja, das hat nahegelegen, dann gibt es auch kein Patent, weil es dann an der finderischen Tätigkeit mangelt. Und wenn jemand auf die Idee kommt, es hat eigentlich nicht nahegelegen, dann gibt es eben das Patent.
Ja, also insofern finde ich es auch völlig gerechtfertigt, dass man so ein Patent vergibt. Allerdings, in dem konkreten Fall sage ich, dass es nicht gerechtfertigt ist, weil nämlich dieses Patent nicht neu war. Das heißt, da ist also dieser zweite Aspekt von Patent.
Neu schon. Auf dem Bildschirm gab es da die Katal-Radar noch nicht, aber es hat möglicherweise nahegelegt.
Falsch, falsch, falsch. Das Patent ist also 1994 an die Firma Adobe, hat 1994 die Firma Adobe eingereicht, so rum. Und da ist eben der Knackpunkt, seh ich mal, weil nämlich z.B. da gab es eben endlos schon Pferde von Prior Art. Die offensichtlichste war z.B. eine US-2 von IBM. Die ist schon in der Version 2, die gab es schon zwei Jahre vor, 1992. Also schon millionenfach für jedermann, um die Käufe zu erwerben, für ein paar 50, 100 Mark oder Dollar oder sonst was. Sie haben also schon dieses Konzept in ihrem Betriebssystem drüben gehabt. Deswegen sage ich, es ist absolut trivial, das war nicht neu.
Na ja, es ist ja ein Unterschied, ob es trivial ist oder nicht neu.
Also ich sag mal, weil es nicht neu ist, ist es trivial.
Man kann sich jetzt streiten über den Begriff trivial, aber ich sag mal, na ja. Also war nicht patentwürdig.
Dann haben die Prüfer entweder OS2 nicht gekannt oder das Patent von Adobe sieht doch ein bisschen anders aus. Das müsste man jetzt im Detail anschauen.
Das wäre auch noch eine ganz spannende Frage eben, worauf sich dann eben dieser diese Patentanspruch erhebt. Weil wenn man dann eben die Beschreibung liest, was ich also getan habe, die ist also auch im Internet und ihr habt ja selber auch vorher angesprochen, genau exakt dieses Patent, worauf sich das ganz genau bezieht eigentlich. Weil so wie die es beschrieben haben, also auf einer Fläche des Bildschirms kann man einen Knopf drücken, damit auf einer anderen Fläche des Bildschirms dann eben ein Fenster erscheint und in diesem Fenster können eben verschiedene Fenster erscheinen. Und das ist eben das Patent, das Geniale, die Erfindung, dass da eben mehrere Fenster auf der gleichen Fläche erscheinen können.
Du kannst auch sicher sein, dass sich hier schon jede Menge Patent-Anwälte mal angeguckt haben.
Peter, danke dir auf jeden Fall für den Anruf, hm?
Na, das war jetzt noch keine Antwort, aber wenn ihr keine Lust mehr habt drauf zu achten...
Ich hab gar keine Frage gehört. Also, was ich da als Frage ausgesucht habe war, also bei den Patenten zählt halt das, was in den Ansprüchen selbst drin steht. Also es ist meistens weiter hinten, vorne gibt es die Beschreibung, die dann doch versucht, verständlich zu sein. Nicht so wie das Beispiel, das wir vorhin hatten. Und tatsächlich ist aber das geschützt, was in den Ansprüchen drin steht. Also bei den englischen Patenten, die, oder amerikanischen, die in diesen Internetdiskussionen meistens auftauchen, gibt es da diesen einleitenden Satz, what is claimed is, und dann anschließend kommen da laufende Nummern, 1 bis 5000.
Die sehen ja über einen Kartellreiter und ist ja auch in Deutsch.
Achso, also beim Deutschen ist es dann genau das gleiche. Also da gibt es dann eben die Patentansprüche, das steht meistens auch so klar drüber. Und die sind dann auch von 1 durch laufenden Nummern nummeriert.
Und die definieren den Schutzbereich. Also da steht genau drin, was eigentlich durch das Patent geschützt ist. Und die muss man sich auch ganz genau angucken. Ich muss dazu geben, ich hab das Kartellreiter-Patent nur sozusagen vom Titelblatt gesehen. Und ich hätte als Patentanwalt natürlich genau in die Ansprüche schauen müssen, um zu wissen, was da genau geschützt ist. Und ob es mir danach immer noch trivial erscheint oder nicht.
Frage beantwortet, Peter. Wir, bin mal, in etwa drei Minuten ist die Sendung zu Ende. Wir müssen uns noch verabschieden. Ich muss noch mal alle Namen sagen, weil wir über 4000 Leute sind. Dauert das ein Sekündchen. Und deswegen würde ich einfach mal sagen, sorry, aber wir machen mal Schluss. Okay, dann mach's gut. So, ist nämlich gleich Ende hier. Gibt gleich den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Wenn noch weiter diskutiert werden möchte, dann könnt ihr das gerne tun. Es gibt noch diverse nicht-sterbende Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten. Also, weil jetzt hiernach ist ja Ende um 1 Uhr. Aber man kann auf diverse Arten und Weisen Kontakt aufnehmen und sich selber verwirklichen.
Genau, ihr könnt auf jeden Fall eine Mail schicken, und zwar an 95.chaosradio.ccc.de, also 95.chaosradio.ccc.de. Oder ihr könnt auf der Mitmachseite im Wikipedia mitmachen. Da findet ihr den Link dahin über chaosradio.ccc.de, wo ihr sonst noch mal alles zur Sendung nachlesen könnt. Es gibt ein Fritz-Bot, da muss der Max was zu sagen. Das kenn ich nämlich nicht so gut.
Ach so, ich war heute faul. Ich hab jetzt kein eigenes Bett eingerichtet. Deswegen hat sich da nichts getan. Aber ich kann noch mal sagen, dass Chaos Computer Club feiert Geburtstag 23. Wenn ihr Infos haben wollt und am 11. September dabei sein möchtet, dann einfach www.ccc.de slash 23, das ist eine Zahl, also 23, eingeben. Und dann könnt ihr euch Infos dazu ziehen. Findet dann in der Seabase statt im September. So, das war's. Wir bedanken uns ganz herzlich bei unseren Gästen, die Fantastisches geleistet haben im Schweiß ihres Angesichts. Unter anderem Philipp Berker, Patentanwalt angehender und Joachim von Oppen, Patentanwalt genauso wie Robert Gehring, Informatiker von der TU Berlin. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart, ihr drei.
Ja, wir danken auch. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Könnt ihr jetzt eigentlich so weitergehen, noch drei Stunden. Jetzt sind wir richtig warm. Ansonsten Frank, Harald und Max hier vom Chaosradio, normalerweise auch dabei. Und wir sagen dann wieder, am nächsten, letzten Mittwoch im Monat ist es wieder soweit. Heute war es mal eine Ausnahme. Dann gibt es die neueste Chaosradio-Ausgabe.
Nein, nein, nein, die nächste ist auch wieder unregelmäßig.
Sag mal, was ist denn eigentlich los hier? das ist typisch, nicht? Das sind diese Jungs vom Chaosradio. Das sind Sie, das seid ihr. Genauso wird da immer argumentiert. Das ist Paranoia.
Gut, Chaos sind die anderen.
Macht's gut. Viel Spaß auf jeden Fall beim nächsten Mal Chaosradio. Einfach gucken, wenn es denn kommt.